hi everyone welcome to day 3 of digital
marketing week by simply learn on day
two we looked at SEO in detail today we
are going to focus on social media
marketing social media marketing allows
you to use social media channels to
Market a company's products and services
it provides companies with a way to
engage with existing customers and reach
new customers social media marketing
also helps to promote the desired
culture and Mission as well it allows
organizations to
improve customer satisfaction so in this
video you will get an introduction to
social media marketing and look at
Facebook advertising you will understand
how to rank YouTube videos increase
Twitter and Instagram followers and
finally learn about the top social media
marketing tools so let's get started
with learning how social media marketing
Works imagine it's the year 2004.
this is Phil Phil's looking to release a
book and set up a Blog he's sure that
it'd be successful but he's only worried
about one thing he doesn't know how to
ensure that his book reaches the right
target audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads Billboards
radio Direct Mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
Phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing the form of marketing
that's a lot more lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise Their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines websites social media
platforms emails Etc among these types
social media marketing cot Phil's eye
social media marketing would give Phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertise this
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about this
book increase the interaction with his
audience It's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get Marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better Phil started by
taking up a certification to learn about
social media marketing since he was
already familiar with the concept of
social media marketing his next step was
to learn about the different types of
content he could post on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that bill could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time Phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content Phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction Phil
could use images from his book advertise
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads
these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from Phil's blog or his book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
you could also use video ads Phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertises books Phil could also use
lead ads through which he could collect
information from users who are
interested in a Weekly Newsletter or
regular updates from his blog but that
wasn't the only thing Phil could do with
social media platforms he could create a
brand for himself and drive audience
interest to it engage with them create
an identity engage with content finding
content that works for him social media
platforms also allowed him the
opportunity to Target audiences based on
demographics like their age location
gender and much more and in time Phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page and by extension his blog he also
saw an increase in the number of people
who bought his book greatly increasing
his audience here are some things he
learned one to set goals that were
quantitative smart and follow a constant
deadline two to understand his audience
by engaging and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
4. using tools like buzzsumo IFTTT
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos but how
did Phil get so good at Social Media
Marketing Phil taken up simply learns
digital marketing course it was thanks
to this course that Phil had the skills
and training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today I mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called The Yellow Pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton I mean those were the ways to get
your product a message out there a lot
of advertising is in those Yellow Pages
then you have Billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise via fax just a
few decades ago so these were all the
ways in which people had to get their
product and service out there it seems
like so archaic looking at it now but
back then that was legitimate that was
the way to do it and then one thing made
our lives a lot easier so if you're a
marketer you're thinking to yourself man
I'm glad I'm a marketer in today's day
and age because it's social media
marketing social media marketing has
made everyone's lives better from the
company that's selling the product
product or service to the marketer
promoting the product and service to the
end user who wants to see that product
or service and engage with that product
or service so social media is a good
source of getting your product and
service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're going to answer that million
dollar question and what's that million
dollar question it's how can you Rise
Above the Rest and so today's session is
going to be how to start with social
media marketing so you can Rise Above
the Rest leveraging this great platform
that we all take advantage of today so
let's start by asking the question what
is social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to increase your
brand awareness and it has other
marketing goals you know so you can
create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing is so again if we want
to increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics and other types of graphics
with the potential to actually go viral
what we mean by viral is spreading like
wildfire one user sending it to another
as rapidly as can be and before you know
it you get you know millions of views
and millions of likes I mean that's the
power of social media marketing so why
do we want to do social media marketing
and I think we just answered some of
those questions but let's dig a little
bit deeper we mentioned in our
definition of social media the marketing
that we have the opportunity to really
build our brand awareness and that is no
more truthful than with social media
marketing more so than any other digital
marketing channel social media marketing
allows us to really put our brand in a
good light in a good position in front
of the right eyeballs so it allows us to
really improve our brand by pushing out
the appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right eyeballs and we are building up a
funnel of prospective customers who then
turn into customers who then turn into
loyal customers who then turn into
lifetime customers we could see at every
step in the process that our conversion
rates may increase we can certainly
leverage social media marketing for SEO
for search engine rankings it's about
off-page SEO it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there is some
inherent benefits to working SEO and
social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on Twitter or Facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say Google or Bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
Brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from seeing
your brand for the first time to to
getting to know your brand a little bit
more to maybe buying a product or
service from your brand then returning
to buy another product in service and
then continuing to buy that product or
service I mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing now we talk
about social media marketing what are
the channels used for social media
marketing how can we use them it's
really social media marketing is a
channel in itself so let's take a look
at the platforms involved with social
media marketing now there are some
really popular platforms so if you can't
tell just buy these logos then you
probably have not used social media
marketing or our social media platforms
before are taking part in social media
at all but you know one would like to
think that the majority of your users
out there today know what Facebook is
what the logo looks like what it does
same with Instagram which is owned by
Facebook LinkedIn B2B platform it's
YouTube great very popular video sharing
platform and then Twitter which is
considered microblogging but still
social media so these are the most
popular popular platforms out there but
there are hundreds of social media
Platforms in fact when we talk about
social media marketing and it can be
anything from microblogging to video
sharing like YouTube to B2B networks
like LinkedIn to say bookmarking sites
like stumbled upon content sharing sites
like Reddit q a sites like quora so
there's plenty of different types of
social media platforms out there in fact
if you folks have any any popular or you
think valid social media platforms that
these listeners here should really get
to know and understand and use then go
ahead and put that in the comments
section underneath this video I'm always
interested in knowing what social media
platforms are out there and what people
are using how platforms are trending
what's popular what's not and ideally as
a digital marketer where my target
audience is so these are the most common
but there are hundreds out there
hundreds so let's talk about the most
popular social media platform and that's
Facebook so Facebook has an average of
2.27 billion monthly active users now
that number is fluctuating because we're
talking about billions billions billions
of monthly active users and that
number's probably trending up 88 of all
users are on mobile so what does that
tell you that tells you that Facebook
has an app and the app is very popular
in fact I 10 and to use the app more
than I use the web page for Facebook
okay so I don't necessarily log on via
the Internet on my laptop I go right to
the app it's just easier easier to
disseminate information easier to add
friends comment respond Etc so it's no
surprise that 88 of all users use mobile
now 66 percent of mobile monthly users
use Facebook daily so a lot of recurring
users going back on a day-to-day basis
two-thirds so it's an addiction more
than it is anything else because what
Facebook is is really you're getting
information from the people you trust
care about like work with share a group
with share common interest with partake
in the same organization maybe have the
same running group same passions I mean
that's what Facebook is it's a
commonality amongst people and if you
build up a network of that commonality
it's going to be a addicting to take
part in that you know the closest
Network you can ever get to is your
family so if your family's on Facebook
then likely you're going to be on
Facebook communicating with your family
via this platform especially if you
don't live close to your family or
especially if you don't live close to
your friends I know in the United States
you know people move a lot for work or
people travel a lot for work and so
Facebook bridges that gap between
distance and you you know you do feel
like you're part of somebody's life on a
daily basis being on Facebook so that's
what makes it The Addictive part so if
you think about it from an end user's
perspective it makes total sense now if
you wear your digital marketing hat
you're thinking hey two-thirds of
monthly users are using it daily and
there's billions of active users then
whoever I'm targeting has to be on
Facebook now if we look closer at the
demographics we could see that a lot
more seniors age 65 plus are using
Facebook so 6 60 plus percent of seniors
are using Facebook so Facebook is
trending older however 35 of the
audience is below the age of 25 so it's
not just trending up it's also trending
down so a lot of young people are still
using Facebook and then Facebook you
know is pretty evenly matched between
males and females now if I'm either
slowing old feeling older or skewing
younger on my target audience and half
female half as male then I know
somewhere in there whoever I'm targeting
is going to be on Facebook just based on
these numbers here so your demographic
is likely going to be on Facebook again
depending on your industry depending on
your product or service but considering
the number of people and how it's
skewing older and younger and everybody
in between Facebook has something for
everyone now Facebook allows for video
content so you could post videos all day
long so if you have YouTube videos you
can share those YouTube videos on
Facebook in fact video just like on most
platforms tends to provide better
engagement and the industries that can
really capitalize on Facebook tend to be
food and beverage news and media and
e-commerce meaning you're selling a
product Facebook has you know plugins
and that allow you to really accentuate
what you're trying to sell when I say
that accentuate I mean really
incorporate an opportunity for people to
use the Facebook platform to not only
just engage not only to share but to buy
taking that process a step further so if
you're selling a product you can more or
less set up a a Facebook shop if you
will and sell your product there so
that's why it benefits those that are
are in the e-commerce industry selling a
particular product or in the food and
beverage industry now some of the most
like Pages I'm Facebook spans across
many many Brands but let's just take a
look at Coca-Cola for example in
Coca-Cola just pretty much pinpoints
everything great about what you could do
on Facebook I mean you could see here
they have their opening page is a video
and so you can see they're posting
different content about you know this is
about a grant how they're helping the
city of Atlanta you know they're talking
about recycling so to me these are
community-based posts so they're not
necessarily just pushing out their
product per se they're trying to use
Facebook to build up brand awareness so
a huge Fortune 500 company like
Coca-Cola is not necessarily just using
Facebook just to push e-commerce to push
a product they're out there you know
pushing what they're doing for the
community so this is a good example of
you know how you can really leverage
Facebook taking advantage of everything
Facebook has to offer and that means
brand awareness Community built you know
sharing you know updated information not
only about the company but in this case
Coca-Cola is situated in Atlanta Georgia
in the United States so you know what
are they doing with the community okay
so this is a good example of course it's
a big example because Coca-Cola is a big
company they're worldwide but the great
thing about Facebook is you can always
take a peek at what other companies are
doing whether you have a million plus
people liking your page or a hundred
plus people liking your page you can
always get ideas as to how they're
leveraging Facebook now if you do have a
company you can create a Facebook page
for your business just like Coca-Cola so
you want to be able to separate out your
business from your personal page and
like everything you do whether that's
writing a blog or creating a video you
want to have original content that's
relevant to your audience you want to
use Facebook for some promotion but
every post doesn't necessarily need to
be be promoting your product or service
you saw what we just witnessed on the
Coca-Cola page it was about what they
were doing to you know benefit the Earth
with recycling or what they're doing in
conjunction with the with the city of
Atlanta so they're more community-based
posts and so to me that's original
content positive content that isn't
necessarily pushing their product per se
now you could argue hey it's Coca-Cola
they have the biggest brand in the world
and that's true but just think about
your product and service think about
your brand if you're trying to build
brand awareness what does your brand
stand for and if your brand stands for
say the the globe the ecosystem the
environment then you probably want to be
pushing out posts in that direction if
that's what you stand for as a brand
then you want people to know that
because like-minded people are on
Facebook and those like-minded people
are going to be the ones who like your
page who engage with your content and
tell other people about it so you always
want to go original you always want to
be true to yourself and true to your
brand and then you could take advantage
of user generated content like sharing a
user's experience of using your product
so in other words if somebody's engaging
with you or they've posted something
about your brand and product you can
reciprocate and you can certainly post
something that is similar to what
somebody's doing with your product or
brand so that's a good way to create
some original content by taking
advantage of what the users have
generated so these are just some
examples of how to take advantage of
Facebook I mean there's lots of things
you can do on Facebook plenty of things
if we float back to Coca-Cola page you
know you can see they have you know
careers they have different videos they
have reviews they have community so
nowhere in here do I see an e-commerce
platform now if you are selling T-shirts
then hey you can put something in there
to help you sell that t-shirt but
Coca-Cola's strategy is hey what can we
do to help build up our community what
can we do to fundraise so if we click on
fundraise you can see they have you know
an N AIDS campaign here if you look at
simply learn just as another example you
can see what simply learns done as well
you could see they have information
about us they have different events they
have a community link as well and so you
can see what they're posting as well and
there you can see they're posting
visitor photos so there's lots you can
do on Facebook you can post polls you
can put your Instagram feed in there you
can add testimonials so there's a lot
you can do on your page you just gotta
get creative and take advantage of
everything Facebook has to offer be true
to yourself and before you know it I
mean you're gonna have you know a number
of likes on your business page as well
so some other tips about Facebook when
it comes to content you want to schedule
your content okay you don't want to just
continue to post back to back to back to
back you want to space your content out
and the another great advantage to
Facebook as I already mentioned about
social media marketing that's
advertising so Facebook owns Instagram
they have a great tool for communicating
called Facebook messenger and so you can
advertise leveraging Facebook Messenger
you can leverage Instagram and what you
need to do is if you go to Facebook's ad
manager and you create a campaign when
you go to create a campaign you're going
to click on placements and depending on
what you're trying to do let's just say
you're trying to build brand awareness
you can actually hone in on you know
Facebook you can hone in on Instagram
you can do a number of different things
within Facebook you have different ads
available to you from single image ads
to video ads to Carousel so you have a
lot of options and the biggest option on
Facebook when it comes to advertising is
your audience who are you targeting so
remember Facebook has old young and
everybody in between between men and
women and so you can specifically Target
interest you can specifically Target
gender and age a location so Facebook
really allows you to hone in on who your
audience is if you're advertising and so
that's the great thing about Facebook
they have a lot of users and you're you
have an opportunity to hone in on a
segment of that user base now Facebook
also has metrics that you can look at to
really understand how people are
interacting with your ads how inner
people are interacting with your post so
let's take a look at that so if we go to
Facebook when you go to your page you
can click on insights and you can
actually see some insights on posts that
have been posted on your page you can
get insights into how many people viewed
it how many people liked it how many
people engaged how many people you
reached with your post okay you have
information about videos followers
Facebook provide its recommendations so
this is all part of Facebook insights so
if you're posting on Facebook Facebook
will give you feedback as to how you're
supposed to perform it now if you're
running ads on Facebook you can simply
just view metrics related to how your
ads are performing so you could see how
many people clicked on an ad how many
people the ad reached how much you've
spent okay you can look at it by
demographic you can even see cost per
result so you can get a lot of good
insights into how your ads are
performing as well so if you're running
a campaign targeting a specific audience
on Facebook you can look at the you know
stats and metrics surrounding that
campaign and again for your Facebook
page you have Facebook insights so if
you have any questions you know feel
free we have a video called Facebook
advertising tips and tricks so feel free
to you know take a look at this video on
simply learns YouTube YouTube channel
for more information about Facebook and
if again if you have any comments to
share about Facebook feel free to put
them under the comments section okay
let's turn our attention to one of the
platforms Facebook actually owns
Instagram so Instagram is a place where
you can actually promote your brand
product or service through the power of
imagery or video and so the average
number of monthly users on Instagram
reaches 1 billion and 32 percent of all
internet users are on Instagram so a lot
of users using it it's very easy
platform to use you just the only
prerequisite you need your mobile phone
so you open up that app it's as simple
as just uploading uploading an image
that's why Instagram is so popular
because it's just a simple tool to use
to go ahead and just post an image with
some hashtags so 68 of all Instagram
users are women so unlike Facebook it
does does tend to slant more on the
female side and 59 of the audience is a
bit younger between age 18 to 29 so
Slants more women and Slims more younger
and so if these particular demographic
and age groups tend to fit your target
audience then Instagram is a place you
probably want to be for social media
marketing so as I mentioned content that
works best are photos or videos I would
always slant towards videos if you have
them available but photos you know the
rule of thumb is photos always tell a
thousand words a thousand stories a
thousand interpretations images are just
always the best way to go as well I mean
if you don't have the videos hey nothing
to be sad about if you fall back on
imagery so you can really put your brand
in a good perspective and a good light
by posting images and as you can imagine
if 18 to 20 nine-year-old women are on
Instagram you know that's skewing
towards a certain demographic but in
terms of Industry it is open to most
Industries but the ones that tend to be
most successful are Beauty food and
beverage and e-commerce now food and
beverage always tends to work well when
you have video and imagery likewise
Beauty but e-commerce if you're selling
that t-shirt or shoe you know Instagram
allows the platform to work in a way
where people can purchase that product
right within the platform so that's why
it tends to work well with e-commerce
okay there are lots of channels just
like on Facebook lots of channels on
Instagram I mean some of the most
followed brands or Chanel Starbucks Nike
I mean if you have a product or service
that you want to push out there then
Instagram is the way to go just for
brand awareness if you're selling shoes
then why not take images of and photos
of those shoes and get them posted on
this Instagram like I said it's very
simple to use all you need some hashtags
to go along with that photo of a shoe or
photo of that cup of coffee and
Instagram kind of takes care of itself I
mean photos do accentuate the product if
you have them so leverage Instagram if
you're really trying to build up some
brand awareness for a particular product
some best practices here on Instagram is
you know have a compelling bio a good
profile picture you know add a link to a
landing page and you know leverage
emojis if you have to so set yourself up
nicely on Instagram you know if you're
in a particular industry like food and
beverage follow other food and beverage
Brands like Coca-Cola like Starbucks
depends on what it is you really want to
be related to so just make sure they're
relevant get hashtags can't stress that
enough you know when you post a photo
there's some hashtags in there you can
see what other people are hashtagging on
Instagram and you can ride that wave of
what's try trending or you can create
your own unique hashtag I'd probably
have two to three hashtags per photo and
don't be afraid to use both photos and
videos videos do tend to work well on
pretty much any platform they tend to
work well on websites and blogs so why
not use them on social media where
people can engage okay so videos and
imageries both work well on Instagram
okay you can also get shout outs from
other influencers you have plenty of
influencers on Instagram especially in
Beauty especially in food and beverage
fashion tends to be another industry
that has a lot of influencers so feel
free to reach out to them reciprocate
see how you can work together where they
can actually you know give you a shout
out on your particular product you want
to keep your Instagram account updated
and you can update those with Instagram
stories it's basically you showing off a
particular product you know over a span
of a few seconds or even a minute that's
an Instagram story they're very popular
uh easy to use you can even run contests
to boost engagement so for example if
your particular product is a particular
food like a hamburger you know hey post
a contest about you know allowing your
followers to post the best good looking
tasty you know Hamburger as an example
or it could be something else in terms
of fashion hey what's your best outfit
on a Friday night before you go out for
the evening you know there's always
things you can do to Spur engagement
especially on a platform like Instagram
where people like to post photos and
then I mentioned this earlier with
Facebook ads you can run Instagram ads
to give a particular post a boost so if
we take a little snapshot of what we
have available in Facebook ads manager
you can choose Instagram as the
particular platform so if you just want
to advertise on Instagram when you go to
your placements you could choose just
Instagram either the feed or the stories
okay so you can choose one of these two
options if you want to want to boost
your posts get some more eyeballs on
that it's a cost per click platform so
anytime somebody clicks it's going to
cost you but you know just like Facebook
you know the cost per click tends to
slant a little bit lower it really
depends on what you're trying to post
when you're trying to post it and who
else is posting but hey the Instagram
feed and the stories could be a good
option if you're really trying to draw
attention to a particular product okay
let's turn our attention now to the B2B
platform called LinkedIn linkedin's a
very powerful popular business to
business platform okay it has 260
million active users monthly and unlike
Instagram or Instagram Slants more
towards women LinkedIn Slants more
towards men 57 so a majority of the
users are men but still you have a lot
of women and solved in on LinkedIn so a
nice you know nice mix between both
genders 38 of the user base are
millennials you know a lot of young
people older people a nice mix from a
business lots of different business
segments different levels of business
different business Industries and
verticals are on LinkedIn so don't be
you know shying away from uh LinkedIn if
you're demographic or target audience
tends to be older just because 38
percent are millennials doesn't mean
anything it means that everybody's using
it just that means that hey you know
more than one-third of the users are
millennials are younger now LinkedIn is
a B2B platform so if you're in the
business of generating business leads
then LinkedIn is the place for you to go
there's opportunities for you to
advertise on LinkedIn okay there's also
opportunities for you to post lots of
different content on LinkedIn so content
that works on LinkedIn can be a Blog it
could be you know particular news
article you know tips and best practices
I've posted videos on LinkedIn you know
it's good for jobs there's a lot of
content on LinkedIn so if we take a
sneak peek at LinkedIn if I just go to
LinkedIn here you know and I just go to
my home uh the start news page you know
I could see the types of content that's
been posted so somebody just posted
something with an image you know then
you got an article down here okay you
got you know an influencer Like Richard
Branson posting so you got a lot of
different types of posts that you'll be
able to see and you know leverage if you
want to meaning when I say leverage if
you see somebody like Richard Branson
posting something hey stay fit and
healthy you know that's an image that's
something about not about business per
se but you know something interesting
and unique so you can see all sorts of
different types of content based on who
you're following on LinkedIn and who
you're connected to some things about
LinkedIn you always want to create an
engaging profile when I say engaging
first things first make sure it's
complete I mean there's lots of
opportunities so if you sneak over to my
profile here you want to be able to post
a lot of information about yourself so
about what you're affiliated with what
jobs you've held what groups you're
associated with what your interests are
what certifications you have so you want
to be able to you know complete your
total profile you can create a company
page for your business so if we go back
to LinkedIn we can just do a search for
say simply learn and let's take a look
at you know their business page so if I
just do a search for simply learn here
so if I select their page you can see
just like your profile page if you have
a business page set up on LinkedIn you
want to make sure it's complete you want
to put information about the company
what jobs are available and you want
your company to associate with that
business page anybody who does does you
know follow that particular business
page part of the organization is going
to be listed under people so and you
want to be able to post just like on
your personal profile if you have a
business page you want to be able to
post unique content I mean you can see
here simply learn is posting you know
some of the accolades that they have but
they're taking that a step further
they're also posting you know
information about you know upcoming
events and webinars so they're probably
seeing a mix of different content and
that's ideally what you want to do on
any social media platform is mix it up
and just like you can on Facebook just
like you can on Instagram you can you
know boost a post per se okay so you can
get that post in front of some
additional eyeballs now of course you
want to optimize your company page for
searches so it really does come down to
how many people are following you but
when you say when we say optimize your
company page just make sure it's
complete with some compelling content
and then increase the number of
followers you have so the great thing
about LinkedIn that I like the most is
that you know you can you know simply
look at other people if I go back to say
the home page you can actually see who's
following what and you know LinkedIn
does give you opportunities to connect
with people okay so if I go to your if
you go to your profile you'll be able to
see other people that have viewed your
particular page and you can connect with
them okay or connect with people who are
like-minded or similar or connected to
people that you know so LinkedIn does a
good job of presenting other people you
can connect with so it makes it easier
for you to increase the number of
followers so having an engaging profile
personal profile you know having an
engaging company page making sure both
your personal and the company page have
all the content necessary have all of it
completed and then increasing followers
posting unique content I mean that's
really the key to LinkedIn now again
with LinkedIn you can use different
media you can use videos SlideShare
presentation images and you can boost
content as I mentioned before you can
boost content on LinkedIn so if you want
to get that content in front of eyeballs
you can do that so let's take a look at
an example of a campaign and what you
could do on LinkedIn in terms of
sponsored content so if you go to
linkedin's campaign manager I mean you
have an opportunity put your ad in front
of a particular audience so really
depends again on who you're trying to
Target just like Facebook which Slants
more towards personal LinkedIn is going
to slant more towards business so with
LinkedIn you have an opportunity to
Target a particular industry a
particular company a particular job
title okay so you could Target
everything business related on LinkedIn
so you can go ahead and create an ad the
ads have imagery to support the ad and
so basically when you set up your ad you
set up your target you can choose your
placement you're going to be able to see
you know who it is you're actually
targeting and you can go ahead and great
thing about LinkedIn is you have
different ad formats and again you can
get really creative with who you want to
Target and just like Facebook you know
LinkedIn has you know some metrics that
you can measure and figure out how your
particular campaign performs by
Impressions by click click the rate even
conversions cost per conversions and how
many leads so LinkedIn has built-in
platform for measuring campaign success
and so the differentiation between
Facebook and Linkedin is really just the
type of demographics that you have to
choose from you know with LinkedIn you
do have you know different options
available based on business like your
job title or job level or industry or
vertical so you have a lot of examples
available a lot of options available to
you on LinkedIn in terms terms of
advertising okay let's talk about
YouTube now so YouTube has 1.9 billion
active users if it was a search engine
it'd be the second most popular search
engine the highest number of monthly
active users in decreasing order starts
at the United States Brazil Russia Japan
and India all big markets all like to
use YouTube but YouTube's popular across
the world just like Facebook where the
app is popular the app on for YouTube is
very popular so 70 of All Views are
generated from mobile so with YouTube
being a video platform you'd definitely
need videos now there's a lot of
Industries on YouTube a lot of
Industries and some of the most
successful brands on YouTube you know
range from logo to Coca-Cola you know
pretty much to every brand if you're a
brand you want to be on YouTube because
of the massive reach that YouTube has to
offer coupled with video and how great
video is and turn terms of Engagement
it's a just a great combination okay so
some best practices here for YouTube you
want to optimize your video for SEO to
get views and so we have a video that
we've created at simply learn how to
rank YouTube videos so if you watch that
video you'll get some really good tips
and strategies about how to you know
optimize your video for YouTube the very
least you want to make sure that you
know using right the right keywords and
the title description and hashtags so
that's a start when we talk about
optimizing your videos you want to
upload regularly and fix the schedule
for your videos because if you're
starting to get followers on YouTube or
subscribers they're going to expect you
to produce more video especially if
you're producing engaging unique
relevant content for that target
audience so we're not saying you have to
have a video once a day or once a week
start small and build up and get on
regular schedule and then you can
organize your videos in the playlist so
you know if we look at simply learn you
know simply learn does a good job of
organizing their videos into a playlist
so all you have to do is go to and see
you simply learns uh YouTube channel and
you can see how it's broken down into
playlists now YouTube also has the
ability because it is global you do have
the ability to provide translations so
if your target audience is from another
country it probably wouldn't be a bad
idea like Facebook and Instagram or like
LinkedIn you can advertise on YouTube
you would just need to do that through
Google ads so with Google ads you're
going to say Google I want to advertise
on YouTube and you have plenty of
available options to available to you
anything from you know pre-roll to
showing up in the middle of a video to
showing up you know before or excuse me
at the end of a video all the way to
Native content marketing where you know
your ad is showing up now next to a
video see plenty of options for
advertising on YouTube and then just
like on Instagram there are influencers
on YouTube you know feel free to reach
out to these influencers and see if you
can collaborate in some way where maybe
you post their video on your channel
they post your video on their Channel
and vice versa so you want to be able to
maybe collaborate somehow to get some
views on your video okay let's talk
about Twitter now so Twitter is a micro
blogging platform and so when I say
micro blogging I mean Limited in
characters Limited in how much you can
actually post but it's very popular it
has 326 million active users per month
and it does tend to slant a lot towards
Millennials a lot of young people use
Twitter and a lot of people use it to
get their news so no longer are the days
of grabbing that newspaper no longer the
days of going maybe to a media news site
online you can quickly go to Twitter and
get get all your news right there in a
feed an easy feed let's take a peek at
Twitter here you know I can get
everything from you know somebody
posting something specific about their
dog you know all the way to his
particular job you know all the way to
Industry news you know all the way to
basically an advertisement all the way
to a specific news article so it's all
here on Twitter in your feed so Twitter
does offer videos so videos do work well
so if I go back here you could see you
know here's a video of Antonio Brown
he's posting a video of his news
conference and another promotional video
so industries that capitalize on Twitter
as you can guess if a lot of people go
there from their news you'll probably
see a lot of news in media and
entertainment on Twitter so that doesn't
necessarily mean that you can't use
Twitter for your brand it really comes
down to target audience some of the most
influential brands are slanting more
towards you know news and media yeah but
you know you got Cosmetics you got
gaming companies you got everybody's on
Twitter okay it just comes down to does
this platform have your target audience
and given the nature of Twitter you know
how can you get your particular brand
product or service out there and so many
characters okay some other advantages
and best practices you could use on
Twitter so I would recommend
implementing Twitter cards and really
all Twitter cards does is allow you to
attach Rich photos or videos and
different media experiences to tweets so
when you can attach you know rich media
like videos and images to tweets it can
help Drive traffic and engagement to
your website all it's going to take is
just a few lines of markup to your web
page and then users who tweet links to
your content will have a quote-unquote
card added to the Tweet that's visible
to their followers so that's how it
works I would certainly look to get
Twitter cards implemented if you are are
going to use Twitter as your platformer
choice for social media marketing so it
does enhance the experience for the end
user and because allows you as an
Advertiser or as somebody leveraging
social media to really enhance your
Tweet and it just provides a better
experience for the end user who's
looking at your Tweet and so like
LinkedIn you can really take a look at
who's trending what's trending on
Twitter so Twitter makes it easy for you
to you know follow so here they'll list
a who to follow so these who to follow
are similar to what you've been posting
or similar to your industry and then
here you can look at Trends you can look
at what hashtags are trending and so if
you click on a particular hashtag you
can you know follow a particular you
know person who or an organization who
tweeted something so you always are
reminded in Twitter who to follow and so
it makes it easy easier for you to pick
and choose who to follow and build up
your following fairly quickly because
Twitter actually provides you with
opportunities on who to follow just like
LinkedIn just like YouTube just like
Instagram there are influencers out
there people who have a large number of
followers who tweet on a regular basis
who tweet original content who get high
engagement these are influencers and
these are the people you want to engage
with so look for those people on Twitter
follow them I mean the rule of thumb is
if you follow someone on Twitter you
know generally they're going to follow
you back so if you can engage and follow
influencers you have an opportunity to
see not only what they're tweeting but
the ability to communicate with them and
engage with them as an influencer so
maybe they can retweet one of your
tweets and get that tweet out in front
of their followers so you can advertise
on Twitter and the unique thing about
advertising on Twitter you can you know
promote your Tweet just like you promote
post on Facebook or Instagram or
LinkedIn but more so I think than any
other platform is the use of hashtags
and so use appropriate relevant hashtags
I always tend to use a unique hashtag
but also depends on what you're tweeting
about if there's something that's
trending and again Twitter will tell you
what's trending in terms of hashtags if
it's something you're tweeting about
then go ahead and use that hashtag as
well you can have multiple hash tags in
a particular tweet and so don't be
afraid to use a unique hashtag along
with a hashtag that's trending because
the whole idea is you want your Tweet to
get noticed and then you can use tweet
chat or some there's some other tools
out there that are available to allow
you to find people to follow and these
people might be interested in your
product or service because you know they
can fit your target audience or you can
connect with like-minded folks who are
in the same industry or have similar
products or interest so tweet chats
available for that reason and you want
to take advantage of these tools because
again with Twitter it's easy to build a
following but you want to build a
following that is going to engage with
your tweets so let's talk about what
tools are available for social media
marketing so when we talk about all
these platforms available to us okay we
talk about Facebook and Instagram and we
talked about LinkedIn and Twitter and
YouTube I mean those are popular
platforms but at the beginning of the
session I mentioned there's hundreds of
social media platforms out there and if
you're posting content on a number of
them you want to be able to organize
that content you want to be able to
organize it and schedule it you know
where it makes sense and when it makes
sense you want to stay organized and so
there are tools available to help you
stay organized tools like HootSuite
buffer or Sprout social okay some of
these tools are available you know at a
cost of a free trial or or at a low cost
per month so regardless of whether using
a free version of one of these tools or
another tool not listed or you're
actually paying for it it's worth the
investment if you're going to partake in
social media marketing and even if
you're on one platform it's still worth
it to have a social media tool available
to help you schedule and not only do
these social media tools help you
schedule they do a lot of other things
too for example they help you measure
the engagement of your post so let's
take example of one of them like Sprout
social so if I go to sprout social here
I can see for a particular company I'm
able to see you know how my post and get
were engaged okay so I can see daily
engagements on particular platforms I
can also you know schedule my post so I
can go ahead and pick a time and date to
schedule them and so I can go ahead and
post something and put it in a queue to
be published for example tomorrow or
next week or whatever the case maybe so
these tools do a lot for you I mean they
help you discover new followers they
give you in-depth reports they help you
stay organized and so to me it's worth
the investment to look at one of the
tools listed here you know these are
some of the more popular ones to maybe
even a free version but regardless of
how much you pay and what tool you're
using it's still worth the investment
just to make sure you're scouging your
post at the appropriate time so you're
not posting something back to back as an
example and you're able to measure
accordingly so it's nice to be able to
go into a tool like Sprout social go to
reports and measure you know in one
place you know how Twitter is performing
or how Facebook's performing or how
linkedin's performing and so that's
what's a lot of these tools provide is
nice reporting options and nice
scheduling options so you can find more
content you can create by using these
tools again you can schedule efficiently
analyze them and you can use insights to
improve your campaign so a lot of these
tools give you nice insights to how the
post was actually engaged and you want
to be able to leverage that and some of
these tools if not all of them have
social listening and social listening is
monitoring what's being posted out there
so what else is posted you can take a
look at and if it's something
interesting or relevant you can go ahead
and follow or take part in that
conversation okay so that's what social
listening allows you to do and a lot of
these platforms have that as a feature
so let's take a look at tips to be a
good social media marketer so some of
the important things you should take
care of are set up a social media
marketing plan when I say set up a
social media marketing plan there's some
questions you want to be able to ask
okay what platforms am I going to use
what's my objective on each platform in
fact and before you choose the platform
you want to figure out what your
objective is in terms of social media so
your objective could be different on
each platform it could be brand
Awareness on Facebook and it could be
promoting a particular product on
Twitter your objective is going to be on
each platform you want to be able to
choose your kpis and align your kpis
with each platform meaning what metrics
are important to your business goals and
you want to be able to figure out okay
what kind of content am I going to post
on these social media platforms so you
want to get organized and put a plan in
place and then you want to create
informative shareable actionable and
relevant content and what I mean by all
that is you want to create unique
content that doesn't mean you can't
Leverage What other people are doing
meaning you know if I'm you know in the
shoe business I can certainly go to Nike
or Adidas or Puma or Reebok and see what
kind of posts they're putting out and
then I could take their cue and do
something similar but I want it to be
unique to me and I wanted to be unique
to my brand and I want to be able to
keep my content visual meaning I want to
be able to use as many photos and videos
as I can that's available to me because
remember videos generate better
engagement I want to be active and
responsive with my customer base meaning
the whole point of social media is to
engage and people are going to respond
they're going to comment they're going
to take part in What you post and so
whatever they do you want to be able to
respond accordingly whether that's
positive or negative and then you want
to measure metrics like conversion rates
and click-through rate so that goes back
to putting a plan in place figure out
what your metrics are and then when
you're posting on a particular platform
you want to be able to lean on those
metrics to make sure you're achieving
your goals so you want to have those
metrics in place beforehand and then you
want to be able to use those metrics
moving forward as you post the whole
idea is if you're measuring what you
post you're obviously going to want to
lean more towards what's working versus
what's not working in a world where a
lot lot of competing different products
satisfy the same requirement you have a
lot of advertisers you want you to try
their product and then you have other
advertisers you want you to try their
product try my product try my product
try my product try no try my product my
product's the best no no no no no my
product's the best try my product well I
want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product well there's
only one way you can prove your product
is better than the rest and that's with
powerful advertising and one of the best
ways to advertise on the Internet is via
social media and through the largest
social media platform in the world and
that's Facebook so today we're going to
talk about Facebook ads tutorial and I'm
excited to teach this class my name is
Rob Sanders I'm with simply learn and
today we are going to talk about all the
different ads that Facebook has to offer
so introduced back in 2007 the Facebook
ads platform has grown tremendously over
the last few years almost four billion
dollars of Revenue in one year so what
does that mean that means there's a lot
of advertisers why is there a lot of
advertisers because a lot of people use
Facebook it's a popular platform so not
only is it popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on Facebook you have the
opportunity to share your product and
your brand with users who you think are
going to buy your product or associate
with your brand and on Facebook you can
do that a number of different ways
specifically in somebody's news feed and
specifically that person's news feed
that again is interested potentially
interested in your brand your product so
there's a lot of ways to advertise and a
lot of reasons why you want to advertise
so I just mentioned one of the reasons
hey it's an opportunity for you to reach
out to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook in fact 2.27 billion
in the third quarter of 2018. and so
when we say spend a lot of time we mean
going to that Facebook profile at least
once a day okay so a lot of eyeballs
throughout the day checking their news
feed on Facebook Facebook also enables
you the advertiser to find the perfect
audience and so that's the great
combination a lot of people on Facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people based on specific
interest specific demographics specific
location so you're really really putting
your product out in front of the right
people at the right time and so the
other positive and pro about Facebook is
it's lesser spend greater reach and what
do we mean by that well traditionally
Facebook is a little bit cheaper than
other online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because says it helps you increase your
brand awareness it's going to help you
allow users to know what your brand is
all about because remember you're
putting your brand in front of
like-minded people or people you think
that are going to associate with your
brand that are going to associate with
your product so you put your brand out
there you incorporate your your
advertisement in somebody's news feed
it's going to add value it's going to
establish trust and credibility
especially if that person's friend is
associated with that brand so instant
credibility if friends and family
members of a person on Facebook are
associated with your brand so it has the
opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on Facebook
active on Facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
Facebook is it also has other features
other advertising features such as
retargeting so you could Target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your service or product but if they
didn't go through the conversion process
meaning they didn't go all the way
through and and buy your product you can
certainly reach out to them again just
like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
a point in time but we can reach out to
them at another point in time and so
Facebook's advertising platform allows
us to do that so it's a great feature
that we could take advantage of that
will talk about more throughout this
session and then it helps increase
Revenue sales and leads and and that's
primarily what most advertisers are
after you know more Revenue more sales
more leads so Facebook allows us to
educate our audience again a targeted
audience about a specific product we
have to offer so the more our audience
knows about our product especially for
their friends and family members and
colleagues are using the product then
the more likely they're going to
purchase so if you go back back to the
other feature higher Revenue less spend
this is the primary reason because you
have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect combination for
advertising perfect combination and so
today we're going to talk about all the
different types of Facebook ads and
we're going to start out with the single
image ad in the single image ad or just
single image advertisements that have an
optional text on top and a link
description that links to the website so
single image ads are probably the most
popular you can see them on probably
your own Facebook feed if you look so in
fact I'll just jump over to my Facebook
feed right now and if I go there what do
I see I see a single image ad here and
it's from Shopify Partners so become a
Shopify partner at e-commerce here list
of qualifications so Shopify must be you
know a brand that is trying to woo my
business okay so they know that somebody
that I'm associated with or maybe I fit
their demographic so they're targeting
my newsfeed with a single image ad so
that's what a single image ad looks like
it's simply just one single image with
some description and the great thing
about this single image if you ever
noticed is the pixels are pretty large
it's 1200 by 628 so it kind of stands
out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if I go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so I can't miss it if I'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to you know
not see the sad interact in some way
especially again if I know somebody in
my network on Facebook or either that be
a friend or fan family members
associated with that product okay in
addition to the single image ads
Facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as Carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you and in
Carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action and so here
you can see simply learn has a example
of a carousel ad where they're
showcasing their different courses so
this allows users to view a range of all
your different products and services if
you have multiple products and services
to offer then the carousel ads would be
a good option for you so in addition to
the Carousel ads and single image ads it
gets a little bit more sophisticated in
terms of Technology where Facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are interactive it's a good
way to really showcase your product your
brand your service and the great thing
about the video ads is they can go from
just a few seconds all the way up to you
know two minutes or excuse me all the
way up to 120 minutes and so you can
really really put a lot of time and
effort into the video ads to really put
your brand out there and so the one
thing about video is it is interactive
most people engage with video and they
tend to get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other forms of ads so the
video ads are really a popular way for
you as an Advertiser to put your brand
or product out there so you can put your
brand and product out there and not just
a few seconds but you know really tell a
nice complete story to get the
engagement to get the person to take the
action you want them to do so that's why
video ads have become very popular
because they tend to get more engagement
more interaction than your traditional
single image ad or say your Carousel ad
so Facebook also allows us to advertise
and then the last type of ad on
Facebook's called The Collection ad and
so these ads combine basically your
video your slideshow or your product
images taken from your product catalog
okay so if you're an Advertiser who
wants to advertise several products at
once then this could be a great option
for you the collection ad so here you
could see the simply learned example
here they're showing you know not only
you know some some good slide shows and
imagery with some good messaging below
that so before we get into the steps for
creating an ad on Facebook let's talk
about some of the important changes that
have happened on Facebook recently in
light of data sharing so really what
Facebook's done is they've made an
important change on how a user data data
is being used for advertising and so
what Facebook's done is they removed
something called a partner category and
that was an ad targeting program which
the targeting option was based on data
provided by a third-party partner so if
you're an Advertiser and you had a third
party partner that provided some
targeted options to you that was known
as a partner category in in summary
Facebook has removed that program and so
now the only way you can gain user
information is if they provide that
voluntary like the lead ad for example
now you have to get the data directly
from the third party now so you can't
have that third party give you that
targeting option anymore you could
certainly again capture the data
Yourself by relying on lead capture
landing pages as an example or the lead
ads and you can certainly still
Outsource Your Average advertising to
lead gen agencies and media buying
companies okay but the partner category
has more or less gone away
okay so now let's get into
how to create a Facebook ad so what are
the steps so the first thing you'll have
to do is set up a campaign so when
you're setting up a campaign you have to
select what kind of spending you want to
do for your advertisement and what you
want to achieve okay so you have to in
other words identify the goal okay so
with Facebook you have two opportunities
at hand here you can jump into an
auction just like Google what you're
going to do is your ads going to enter
and into an auction and so this is where
you can decide how you want to spend
your money to achieve your goals by
choosing an appropriate bid strategy for
the auction so in the auction you're
competing with other advertisers another
option is you could do reach and
frequency and so with reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise to
your Brand's audience with a fixed cost
so reaching frequency allows you as the
advertiser to better predict the
delivery cost and reach of your branding
campaigns so with auction you have more
choice you have flexibility you have
scalability but not a lot of
predictability okay because again you're
going into an option and your auction is
going to be competing against other
advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so that's the
unpredictability part is the pricing so
pricing can fluctuate during the auction
because you have different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad with reach and
frequency you'll be able to plan and set
up your campaigns and actually set it up
so it's more predictable on how the
delivery is going to be done with reach
and frequency so more predictability
when reaching frequency because you
could set everything up in your campaign
okay so again with the reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise
with a fixed cost auction you're not
necessarily going with a fixed cost
you're going more scalability
flexibility on cost that can change okay
so once you choose your objective for
your advertisement then you need to
choose the type of advertisement you
want to do and it's based on your
objectives so what's your objective is
its awareness to drive awareness is it
to drive consideration or is it to drive
a conversion so these are the three
objectives uh available to you for your
advertising you want to choose one of
those objectives so let's take a look at
each of these objectives available to
you okay so let's start out with
awareness so awareness can help with
creating an interest for your product or
or your service so when we say awareness
is where they can maybe brand awareness
or product awareness to get out there in
front of people okay so with
consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people to think more about our
product and service and have them take
the next step so with awareness you're
introducing your product and service
with consideration you're getting people
to take the next step and start looking
for information about the product or
service you're advertising and then
conversion is kind of that final step if
you're really after conversion you
really want that person to make the
decision okay so they're either going to
buy or use your product or service okay
and so that's the conversion objective
so you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so let's go back to
awareness okay so if we look at
awareness under awareness we have brand
awareness and we have reach okay so when
we look at Brand awareness really what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
increase awareness about our brand or
the product and our brand so these types
of objectives I mean meaning awareness
don't really emphasize interaction okay
you're not really trying to get somebody
to purchase or or buy something or opt
into a newsletter really your goal as an
Advertiser with brand awareness is to
get your product out there so people are
aware that it exists okay let alone
forget about buying it or opting into a
newsletter you really your goal with
awareness and brand awareness is to get
people to see that you're existing your
product exists your service exists it's
available and really the aim is to
create high brand recall amongst users
rather than focusing on generating
Revenue so when we say you know High
brand recall what we mean is hey if your
brand is out there and you are really
pushing it out there amongst a large
targeted demographic audience then the
next time that audience sees your brand
they're going to be able to associate
with it okay it's not going to be
foreign to them or the first time
they've ever seen it you really want
them to recall hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before okay that's
kind of the reaction you want to get
from a brand awareness hey that's a cool
looking logo or man that product looked
interesting now I'm going to take the
next step so that's what brand awareness
really needs to do it needs to create
that recall for that for your audience
okay so let's take a look now at reach
so with reach reach ensures that our
advertisement is seen by the maximum
number of people within our target
audience and budget so with reach we're
really trying to reach or get our ad out
there to as many people as possible
given who we're trying to Target and
given the amount of money we have to
spend so it helps to Target a smaller
audience to visit your website watch
your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to consideration
so we talked about awareness we talked
about brand awareness and reach
with consideration we have you know
people who are willing to take that next
step okay so if we're targeting a
specific demographic and we're looking
at consideration we really want them to
do something with our ad we don't want
them just recall it or see it for the
first time we want them to take that
next step and so with consideration we
have traffic so if we have an ad you
know the least we want somebody to do
who's seen our brand before is at least
click on our ad okay so we want people
to you know click on our ad and go to
our website really that's a goal of
consideration is hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before let me click
on this and see what they have to offer
so this might involve them listening to
a podcast or reading an article or being
introduced to an app so really you're
setting the stage for further down the
funnel by further introducing them to
something that's on your website so you
really want them to take that next baby
step the next baby step is clicking on
the ad going to your site and further
educating themselves about your
particular product or service so
Facebook shows these advertisements to
people within your target audience based
on their past Behavior okay so that's a
great thing about Facebook it's you can
really really get targeted here with
your audience okay so engagement so we
talk about traffic we're going to talk
about engagement so these types of ads
are useful when we want users to engage
more with our ad for example we can you
know really have an advertisement or
post that will allow people to like it
they can respond or even take advantage
of an offer so that's what we mean by
engagement we really want people to
react positively within Facebook about
our ad or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement meant an
engagement audience for your Facebook
page that can be used for future
advertising campaigns so we're really
getting people to take that next step
and what's that next step if they don't
go to our website they can like what we
have to say and then we can have app
installs so that's another option to us
for consideration so app installs are
great if we want to send users to an app
store for example so they can download
our app so if we're really really
pushing an app that we just developed
then an app install could be a good
opportunity under consideration to allow
that user to take the next step and
download your app so that that at a
later stage they can go and interact
with the app we have video views so
video views are are good advertisements
when you're promoting your product or
service and you really want a high
number of views so remember early on we
were talking about the types of ads
available on Facebook we talked about
video views how they get 10 to 30
percent more engagement well that's
really what we want videos to do under
consideration we really want people to
understand what we're trying to do and
really engage with our product and so
they could turn around and like it they
could turn around and um push it out to
their friends so video we know is high
engaging with an audience and so having
a video allows you to really allow that
video to potentially go viral okay so
video views help users engage and
enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements okay so highly engageable
you know interactive allows people to
you know really really take that next
step with your product or service by
really getting to know what you're all
about okay then we have lead generation
so lead generation is interesting
because remember those leads ads we
mentioned in the when we're talking
about the type of ads that Facebook has
to offer well Lee need ads or you know
if you have a lead generation type ad
really what you could do is you can just
collect the information so really
somebody's interest in your product or
service right away then you can generate
a lead ad and allow them to say hey you
know what I'm interested I'm going to
sign up for your newsletter or yes I'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your CRM
so for example Salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with Salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point so that's consideration so
we have a lot of good options available
to us under consider duration you know
we could drive traffic video views app
installs just regular engagement you
know and then we got Legion so we got a
lot of opportunities for consideration
if you're really trying to Target people
who are already familiar with your brand
or product or service and then last but
certainly not least we have messaging so
with messages you know these ads aim to
convert a user's interest in a product
to a successful sale or conversion so it
targets people who are more likely to
respond through Messenger so Facebook
Messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with Facebook and
so with Facebook Messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through Messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
Messenger to your advantage you can talk
right right away to somebody who is
really interested in considering your
product or service so this is kind of
the Capstone of consideration because it
takes into account one of Facebook's
most popular features which is Messenger
it allows you as an Advertiser to use
that feature to engage with your
targeted audience directly let's turn
our attention to the last objective
which is conversion so under conversions
we have conversions product catalog
sales and store visits so for
conversions really this is the end of
the funnel this is really the part of
the funnel where we want people to take
action so ads related to the objective
of conversions really aims to increase
you know whatever the goal is of your
website so if it means sign ups or
registrations for your services or sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website then that's the conversion
okay so that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so you have conversions
and you have you know prior product
product catalog sales so for product
catalog sales these could be ads to help
promote your e-commerce store or other
products in your store portfolio you
know so think of Amazon think about all
the products they have on their website
you know they are probably likely going
to choose you know product catalog sales
because it really will help really push
traffic to the store and really get
somebody to convert either in a for a
particular product or get them to look
at other product categories and buy
something there so it really really
product catalog sales are really great
for future campaigns when you're really
looking for sales and then we have store
visits and so store visits really help
direct traffic to your location and
really helps deliver ads based based on
your user's current location okay so if
we really want to get somebody to the
store if you have a brick and mortar
store for example then you can use store
visits as your objective under
conversions to really Drive traffic to
that location so that's what store
visits are we really want people to you
know take that next step get to your
store and check out your store and
purchase so that's what store visits are
under the conversion subjective So
within each of these advertisement
objectives we can create split tests
also known as a b testing and the reason
why we call it a b testing because what
you're doing is you're testing one
variable from the other so really you
have two advertisements that really are
the same except the only difference is
there's one thing that's altered from
the other so in this example we have a
with one promotion and then we have B
which is the same audience same
everything except different promotion so
you're really changing one variable when
you do a split test and so that's
available to Facebook just like any
other type of advertising let's say you
do you know search advertising on Google
split testing is available let's say you
do email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
Facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same ad and able to
change one of those parameters so you
can see really what ads performs best
that's the whole idea behind a split
test okay so if it's the original sales
sale of 25 off then hey so be it you
know it works because you tested it
against another variation and then the
great thing about testing it never ends
so if 25 off works over say two thousand
dollars off then you try something else
to see if that will increase sales
that's the whole idea behind testing is
you only want you always want to see
what works okay so really what it comes
down to is it can be really it could be
a promotional offer or it could be
something as simple as changing the call
to action you know a different color on
the call to action it could be anything
you want to test as long as you're able
to you know figure out what works and
then apply what works so you can
continue to improve your advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a b
testing okay so it really is identifying
an element you want to test and then
really once you identify that element
and you test it and you know what wins
then you can move on to other things to
figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion then go on to the
CTA so you could test things like colors
and call to actions and imaging and
messaging and positioning and you could
play around with your target audience
and test a segment of a target audience
against another so there's lots of
things you could test when you a B test
the most important thing to note though
when you a B test is you always want to
keep in mind what metric you want to
measure the test up against so some of
the metrics you could use are
click-through rate which is CTR cost per
click CPC you can use conversion rate
also known as CR or just clicks the
whole idea is when you do a test and
you're testing a promotional offer
you're testing even the call to action
you need to measure that up against a
metric so that metric is what's going to
determine the winner and so it doesn't
have to be overly complicated it could
be as simple as testing you know one
call to action against another and
determining which one gets more clicks
and if one gets more clicks than the
other then hey you know you have a
winner okay let's go through the steps
of creating a new campaign on Facebook
using Facebook's ads manager so you're
going to log into facebook.com ads
manager and you're just going to click
on the create new campaign button and
when you do that you're going to see a
screen that looks just like this and
you're going to go through a series of
steps so as we presented earlier the
first step is always choosing your
objective so we have awareness
consideration and conversion so recall
that awareness was getting your brand
out there to people who never seen your
brand or product or service before so
it's a matter of trying to reach as many
people as you can to get your brand out
there and so you have brand awareness or
you have reach remember one is
controlled one is uncontrolled okay so
reach is a little bit more control
because you can set your budget okay and
you can control your budget a little bit
better so brand awareness is just
getting it out there having Facebook
plop it in front of the item front of as
many people as possible with reach you
are trying to maximize how many people
you show your ad to but it is a little
bit more controlled against the budget
okay either way choosing awareness is
going to set the objective of trying to
maximize your exposure for your brand
your product or your service okay if
somebody has already seen your brand or
somebody's already familiar with your
product or your services then you may
want to choose the objective of
consideration and so these are people
who again are already familiar who you
want to take that next step remember
Facebook is an environment where you're
targeting a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service so
you want to take that next step that's
what you want them to do okay so here
under consideration we have traffic
engagement app installs video views lead
gen or messages all all of these choices
are getting somebody to do something for
you for example app installs you want
them to install your app or engagement
you want them to like or share your post
video views watching your video or
messaging you want them to interact with
you via Facebook's messenger feature so
all of these are interactions of some
sort where somebody's taking that next
step they've seen your brand they're
interested but you they're not ready
quite ready to purchase yet okay so
that's what consideration is then you
have conversion this is people in the
funnel who you know or think you know
want to convert and when I say thank you
now meaning you know you're really
targeting people who you've targeted
before
who maybe has purchased from you before
or is exactly the type of audience
you're looking to purchase okay so you
have conversions you have catalog dog
sales and you have store traffic meaning
driving foot traffic to a store okay so
these are people further down the funnel
who you don't necessarily want to take a
smaller action like just share your
Facebook post or provide their email
address and name okay so you want them
to purchase so these are the three
marketing objectives you're going to
choose from okay so we're just going to
choose conversions for the sake of this
example and then when we go to choose
conversions remember we can create a a b
split test okay so that's a choice you
should always choose because you always
want to be testing something okay in
this case we might want to test the ad
we might want to test say the call to
action because we're looking for
conversions so it could be as simple as
having one ad with a buy more and the
other AD that says hey check out our
website so you have that option to a b
split test and then you have budget
optimism station which basically allows
you to set your budget evenly across
your different ads okay and so what
Facebook's going to do is basically make
sure that the best performing ad is
going to be seen more often so that's
budget optimization you're maximizing
your budget towards an ad or ads that
you want to be able to have more control
over in terms of what's working and
what's not working versus not selecting
this option your ads are just going to
randomly show and there's not going to
be any necessary control over how much
spend each ad gets so that's the first
step in creating your campaign it's
always choosing your objective with a
few options built in
so the next step in the process is AD
set okay and as you can see here before
you even get to ad set what uh Facebook
is prompting us to do is look at
basically how the A B test is going to
work so here they're explaining how an A
B split test works okay so basically
what an A B split test does is serve up
50 50. the original versus A variation
of the original okay so that's more or
less how an A B split test works and so
Facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging okay because
that's what we chose now notice we chose
conversions that are objective okay so
what we're going to be required to do is
put a conversion pixel on our website so
that Facebook can actually track
conversions and so what we want people
to do is purchase
and so what we need to do then is add a
Facebook pixel to our website so that
Facebook can actually track how many
people purchase from your campaign so
this is very important and so if you're
driving traffic to your website and you
want them to convert then you need to
make sure all the tracking is in place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide go ahead
and select on because the default is set
to off okay what you could do is you can
associate it with your particular
company page
on Facebook and then you're going to
create your offer so I'm going to put my
offer title I'm going to put a little
bit more details in there I can put an
end date when the offer expires in a
specific time so based on what you put
this is what people are going to see
with the ad and here you have the
Redemption section where you can have
people redeem the offer online or online
and in store so if it's online you need
to provide Facebook with a URL where
people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer and then you have a
chance an opportunity to add a
particular code so you don't necessarily
have to have a code with your offer it
could be a one-time code or it can be a
unique code okay or unique codes okay
and then you have an advanced option
here and this Advanced option is pretty
important because if you're setting up
an offer and you only want a specific
number of people to see that offer then
and you don't want them to to share that
offer then what you could do is hide the
share option so that way people won't be
able to share the promotion with friends
or family or whatnot now they could
still copy and paste the link of the
offer but they won't be able to easily
do it with the share option and here you
could put some terms and conditions so
that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the Wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer to get people to you
know again your objective is to get
people to convert so an offer always
helps incentivize conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing okay
so here we're we're choosing what we
want to split test so if we choose
creative basically what we're doing is
we're telling Facebook we want to test
our creative or at and so now what we're
going to do is we're going to select the
audience and so we could choose a custom
audience a look-alike or all so here you
can see we have a look-alike and a
look-alike basically is basically what
Facebook does is they're trying to find
people who are very similar to your
customers okay so that's who you want to
Target people who look like your
customers on Facebook okay so you can
choose the look-alike audience or you
could choose a custom audience if you
already have one so we're going to
create a new custom audience here
and basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website visitors
okay so we're going to create this
audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell Facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where those
visitors going to come from so we want
to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to United States
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have a specific set of locations
you can upload that
after you choose your location you're
then going to choose your age so here
you have if you look all the way down to
13 years of age and then your range goes
all the way up to 65 years of age then
we have our gender we can choose both
men and women or just men and just women
and then we can Target a specific
language if we want to Target Spanish
people or people who speak Spanish then
we can choose Spanish notice we can add
multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if I click
suggestions then for example Facebook's
going to offer us up some suggestions so
if we want to Target people who have an
interest in foreign language your
charity and causes or mindfulness or it
could be specific job titles okay so we
can get really detailed with our
targeting we also have connections so
who do we want to Target so are these
people who like our page who are friends
of people who like our page we can also
exclude people who like our pitch okay
so remember your advertising is tied to
a Facebook page however you could still
drive that traffic to your website but
what Facebook does is once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a Facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea of what
type of community do you have on
Facebook okay so that really helps them
offer you more detailed targeting in the
form of connections okay so when we're
done we could save the audience
so I'm just going to name it uh English
and Spanish click save okay now I have
my audience saved and the important
thing here is that this audience is
saved we can use it at a later date or
if we're setting up a new campaign we
can pull from the same audience under
use a saved audience
so if I just type in English in Spanish
you'll see my audience here okay and we
can always edit it if we need to
okay so next is the placements section
so here placements is where we want to
show our ads okay so we want to be able
to place our ads in the proper placement
and so what Facebook does is they
actually recommend you do an auto
placement and so Facebook Will based on
your audience show your ad in different
spots or different placements throughout
Facebook based on the people you're
trying to Target the audience okay so in
this case we're targeting both Spanish
and English okay and we're targeting 13
to 65 year olds who live in the United
States and so what Facebook's going to
do then because we have automatic
placement set up is they're going to be
able to place our ads based on our
target audience so this is an option I
always recommend you do and Facebook
recommends as well if you're specific
about where you want your ad to be
placed then you can just select edit
placements and notice when you select
edit placements here you have different
options not only on Facebook but on
Instagram as well okay and Facebook's
Network and in Facebook Messenger so you
have all these different options
available to you if you really want your
your ad placed in a specific position so
here if I just scroll over here I can
see what it looks like in a feed and
stream video I can scroll down to
Instagram that's what it looks like in a
feed on Instagram okay uh you have
Instagram stories if I want to go and
advertise on Facebook Messenger then I
have some options here in messenger
inbox or sponsored messages okay so you
have a lot of options available under
edit placements meaning picking your
placement specifically but again I
recommend as does Facebook just go with
the recommended placements for now
unless you're really clear and you
really under understand how Facebook
works and where these placements are
actually going to be but remember if you
choose edit placements and place it in a
specific position let's just say on
messenger inbox remember your audience
may not be there so go in with the
automatic placements you know is a way
for Facebook to help you get your ad in
front of the Right audience here the
next section delivery optimization okay
how much of our ads are optimized and
delivered so remember we chose
conversions here so we're going to
optimize our ads for conversions so what
Facebook's going to do is take into
account each conversion that e-chat is
getting and they're going to show that
ad that's getting more conversions more
often than the ads that aren't getting
as many conversions okay so they're
optimizing the ad delivery based on how
many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well well
so you can put a cost control in place
so you have an average cost per purchase
okay so Facebook will aim to get the
most purchases and spend your entire
budget okay if you put in an average
cost per purchase so for example if I'm
selling T-shirts I may not want my
average cost per purchase to be twenty
dollars because I'm not going to make
any money so I'm probably going to
choose maybe two three four even as high
as five dollars on a cost per purchase
because I want to make sure I'm not
spending a lot of money just to get a
purchase so you have that option
available to you to put in as a cost
control
and here we have a conversion window and
so with this conversion window is going
to do is you know help Facebook optimize
your ads a little bit better based on
the number of conversions that happen in
this window
okay so you have some other options in
here you want to do standard delivery ad
scheduling you can run your ads on a
schedule or you can run them all the
time okay and then moving down to the
next option in our ad set is we have
split test and split test budget and
schedule so we have the opportunity to
put a budget in place for our ads okay
and we can schedule the the A B test to
start running immediately if we want to
or we can have the A B test run at a
specific date and we can have it run for
a specific period of time so this goes
all the way back to the first option
where we chose a b split test on step
one so we have a series of options
available to us for the split test okay
once we have all our options in place
okay we're going to click continue
and then the final step is actually
setting up our ads Okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a Facebook page it's
going to be tied to an Instagram account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad so remember we have a lot of
different options available to us on
Facebook we have the carousel which
allows us to have multiple images
scrolling horizontally we can have that
single image ad we can have a video we
can have a collection of images
so we have a lot of options available to
us
and then what we could do is we can link
up our ad to a specific page okay now
before we do that we want to be able to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay
and then we're going to add some text to
support that image okay and so when we
add text and for our ad we have the
option of setting up a headline actually
it's not an option it's actually
mandatory the description is actually
optional okay but my recommendation is
you want to add a headline that's going
to grab attention and you want to add a
description to support that headline so
I always recommend putting in a
description and then once you do that
you're going to add your destination URL
and then you're going to be able to
preview your ad okay so if we have an
image here okay we can just say hey this
come check out our new product and so as
I add
this information I'll be able to view it
on the right side okay so it looks like
Facebook at this Point's not able to
view the image but normally you're able
to see a preview in this case it's on
the mobile news feed so if we drop down
we can see desktop right column okay so
we need to really choose our images so
we're going to change an image here
let's see if I can choose another image
okay I'm going to choose an image here
and so now I can see the image now I
could see the headline
um and and then I could see what it
looks like just by changing the
placement okay so if I want to choose
Facebook Stories whoops that's not
available if I go to for example instant
articles okay here I can see what my ad
looks like on instant articles
so it wasn't available on certain
placements because of the type of AD we
chose but the point being when you set
up your ad you choose your image and you
write your headline and put your
destination URL in then you'll be able
to preview it on certain placements
depending on what type of ads you chose
okay once you're set once you're set up
and remember we're setting up a b
testing so that was add one now we want
to test the second ad or the variation
and so basically what we want to do is
choose the same type of format then what
we want to do is pick a variation what
is that variation going to be it could
be maybe just a different headline okay
or it could be a different URL you need
to decide what it is you're going to
test once you decide what you test
you're going to add that to variation B
once you add that the variation B then
you have both ads set up
once you confirm Facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria okay and if it doesn't in
this case you could see we have some
errors
then we need to go back and fix them so
I'm going to go back and choose a single
image ad okay so now
I could just choose my one image
so I can browse a library of images I
already have
now here's my single image ad I'm going
to add some text in there a website URL
a headline
remember you want it to be catchy okay
you can change the call to action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose
so remember we chose a B test so we're
going to set up both ads add a and add B
okay and when we do that again we can
have Facebook review it once they review
it we they can confirm this you can see
we still have some errors on add a so
let's go ahead and fix that I'm going to
choose single image because that's what
add B is I'm going to browse my library
maybe I'll just test a different image
I'm going to click continue
and so basically keep everything the
same what I'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an A B test
knowing what it is you want to test
ahead of time okay once you do that
you're going to go ahead and continue to
add B and then once you do that
um here let's go ahead and fix this
error here
um the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add B
once I confirm then I have two ads ready
to go on specific placements or excuse
me automatic placements and this option
is that's the option we chose and
basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions we have
a set budget and we're going to be able
to then once our ads go live is look at
some reports to see how they're
performing so that's the steps in
setting up a campaign on Facebook you're
choosing your objective okay then you're
setting up your ad set okay and then
once you set up your ad set with your
target audience then you're actually
going through the motions in this case
we set up two ads because we chose a b
testing okay and if you didn't choose a
b testing then you would just choose to
set up the first ad and once you do that
you confirm and voila your campaign is
set up based on these three steps choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access us to 1 000 Plus hours of video
content for free visit skillup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more okay so let's
uh review with some do's and don'ts of
Facebook so we mentioned the types of ad
that Facebook has we mentioned how to
set up a Facebook ad itself and choosing
the right objectives and so some of the
dues involved are what just what I
mentioned we always want to do a b
testing on our ads whether that's again
just changing out the color or changing
out an image you always want to do a b
testing because Facebook has you know
Carousel ads and because they have you
know ads that can rotate and you can use
even video with your ads you always want
to take advantage of what's given to you
and so Facebook allows you to do it do
it so if you have the opportunity to
have a video ad then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definite do is
use engaging videos and imagery so you
don't necessarily have to use a static
ad or image ad you can use the carousel
for example with a presentation mode
where you can show multiple images to
really showcase your product and service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so use a message that will stay with the
audience okay so use something that's
going to be able to trigger remember
depends on the funnel and where you're
at so if your awareness or consideration
or conversion that has to align with
your messaging so if you're you know
targeting ads you know when you want
people to convert then your message is
going to be as such you're going to talk
to people as if you want them to convert
as if they're ready to convert and you
want to keep your message consistent and
simple so remember the ads are available
to you and you have so many different
features available to you within the
Those ads but that doesn't mean you
gotta convolute it with messaging so
keep your message just consistent and
simple if it's brand awareness you know
definitely keep your message simple so
that people can understand exactly what
it is your product or service is all
about then you want to alter your reads
so that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience okay so you always
want to keep in mind who you're trying
to Target okay so you don't want to
Target somebody who's not in your
demographic so alter your reach so that
the ads are shown to the appropriate
audience remember you have you know
reach available to you and reach allows
you to really pick and choose exactly
who you're targeting to and how often
remember you want to reach as many
people as possible but you don't want to
reach the wrong people okay some of the
don'ts to stay some things you want to
stay away from is you don't want to put
all your money on one campaign so you
want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across different
campaigns and and I would even take that
a step further and you know put
different types of ads in different
campaigns just to see what works so
again it depends on where you're at in
the funnel if it's just brand awareness
okay maybe create a campaign for that if
it's consideration create a campaign for
that because in consideration you might
have lead ads in them they say with the
awareness campaign you may just have a
single image ad okay just to introduce
your product to somebody with a simple
message so you want to you know
definitely think about how you want to
separate out your campaigns but don't be
afraid to separate your campaigns by the
type of ads don't put too much
information in the ads remember keep it
consistent and keep it simple that's the
best thing I can say and remember a lot
of these ads are image based so images
tell a thousand words they tell a
thousand stories a video will do the job
if you have to say too much so if you're
saying too much think about a video but
if you're using image let the image tell
the story okay don't forget to proofread
your ads I can't stress that enough
remember if you're an awareness campaign
this is the first time somebody's seen
your product or service so you
definitely want to get the messaging not
only correct meaning consistent and
simple but grammatically correct you
don't want to be so active on your
Facebook page so you know when I say be
don't be so active on your Facebook page
really it depends on where you're at
you're trying to introduce a product or
service so that doesn't mean that you
need to go out and tell everybody to
start buying your product remember these
people may not even know who you are
what product and service you offer so
you want to be able to approach your
audience on your Facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
Facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don'ts you
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising today we're going to
cover a number of tips to help you gain
a better advantage on advertising on
Facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on Facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
an app so it all goes back to your
objective so if we go to Facebook and I
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration it
AF conversion so depending on what you
want somebody to do that's the objective
you're going to choose so just keep that
in mind when you're setting up your
campaign on Facebook you need to align
your objective with what you want people
to do so tip number two we want to use
Facebook Messenger for advertising so
Facebook Messenger is a feature that can
be used with advertising on Facebook and
it's a good tool it's a good practice
because it'll allow you to as the
advertiser to commute with individuals
directly so it's a feature that you
should take advantage of because it
allows you to quickly engage with your
target audience so that's the beauty of
leveraging Facebook Messenger with your
advertising the communication tools
available and for you to engage with
your target audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have as
an on as an audience or prospective
client so you can answer any concerns
they have right away so it's a lot more
personal and interactive than other
forms of advertising because you're
directly communicating with your
audience tip three use video
advertisements I can't stress this
enough video is very engaging in fact
it's not only engaging but it's very
easy to use so if we go to Facebook
really Facebook is telling us for video
all we need to do is have basically a
phone handy and an app Facebook all you
need is a mobile camera so with Facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just got to be creative that's
really the key to videos you know
they're going to be engaging to the end
user say something do something that's
going to really grab their attention and
get them to do what you want them to do
so these are just some of the examples
you can see on Facebook and you can see
how creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so I can't
stress video enough as an option for
Facebook it really is one of the better
features of Facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera and app and
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why I'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional Facebook
image ads and other formats like the
carousel or the presentation mode so
there's other types of formats on
Facebook video tends to give it that
extra Edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're going
to comment they're going to share the
video and that's what you want as an
Advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it'll help you not only engage with
the person but allow out that video to
be shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience so remember video
can range from a few seconds all the way
up to 120 minutes so you're really gonna
get more views regardless of how long
the video is because it's just going to
be so interactive so just keep that in
mind it doesn't have to be full on 120
Minutes it could be you know anywhere
from one to five minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have that lead way if you
wanted to so remember video ads always
perform better than single image ads or
other type of image ad formats on
Facebook and they also perform better
when they have subtitle support so just
keep that in mind as well because you
may have you know individuals watching
the video from you know different
countries speaking different languages
say tip four when you're placing your
advertisement where you place your
advertising and play an important role
in deciding how many people come across
it so Facebook offers a number of
different options to to choose from so
remember you got the news feed you got
instant articles right column you got
suggested videos so you got a lot of
options at your disposal there's lots of
other options too so you can have
Facebook actually automatically place
your ads or you can specifically tell
Facebook where you want to place your
ads and that's all part of the Facebook
setup so if we go to Facebook and then
we go to create your campaign so if we
close ad sets here is where we're going
to be able to choose our placement if we
click on choose placement we'll be able
to you know be able to allow Facebook to
place it or we can edit the placement
specifically so just keep that in mind
you have a lot of different options here
again feeds and articles in-stream
videos rycom you even have Instagram so
you have a lot of options available to
you so my recommendation and Facebook's
recommendation is always go with the
auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're setting up your
campaign so start the advertising on the
news feed could be recommended the news
feed is where you're probably going to
get your most eyeballs most users spend
most of their time there and it has the
highest chance of grabbing their
attention so the news feed could be a
good place to start again you can have
it at Auto placement and your ads may be
there as well or you could specifically
choose just the news feed or other
placements so tip four just be careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you want to place your ad
where you're going to get eyeballs so
tip five Facebook ads also offer you the
option to advertise on Instagram so you
have that option available to you as I
mentioned in tip four you have the
option to advertise these stories
Carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all part of the ad setup
when you go to choose your placements
here you got Instagram feed you get
Instagram stories and again with both of
those placements on Instagram you can
work with several different types of ads
including that Carousel ad including
that video ad so just keep that in mind
that Instagram is an option for you take
advantage of it there's a lot more
eyeballs on Instagram these days and it
plays off nicely with what you're trying
to do with Facebook so go ahead and give
it a try Okay so let's take a quick
break from the first few tips we went
over and let's take a look at an ad so
it's an ad break time so let's take a
look at this ad this is by New Scientist
and so what makes this ad so great well
there's been a lot of shakeup in the
world today about fake news you know
what is fake news so new scientists is
actually playing off of that they're
mentioning hey fake news not in our
world so they're actually playing off of
that that term fake news and so that's
an attention grabber so I think that's
what makes this look so good but this is
a single image ad and you can see here
they're promoting this ad with a
promotion so try 12 weeks for just US 36
Euros okay so they have a promotion in
there so and you notice they the image
of the you know the magazine they're
also displaying that hey you can look at
this digitally on a laptop a tablet or a
mobile phone so you have other options
as well so they show you that in the
image which is placed on the right side
of their messaging so for me this is a
good ad because of the placement of the
image the type of image they're using
the play on fake news and the promotion
that they're offering up so this is
really a good ad it's very eye-catching
and hopefully the promotion is good
enough to get you to sign up okay so tip
number six so tip number six we want to
continuously do a b testing you want to
always have this option going for you
you want to be able to test variation a
versus variation B because you want to
be able to find out what works and what
doesn't work with your audience and on
top of that it helps you really put your
best foot forward by showing your best
ad so by doing a b testing you're
getting feedback from the audience and
turning that feedback into positive
returns so you're then turning your ad
that does work well in front of an
audience and you're going to continue to
do that so A B testing is always a good
option so remember when you're setting
up your ad in Facebook go ahead and
choose to have your A B test set up and
when you do that you choose that option
you're going to be able to then go in
and choose what it is you want to test
without a and then with ADD B so you're
going to again align your test with a
Facebook page you're going to choose an
ad format once you choose your ad format
then you're going to be able to go ahead
and you know put your ad in there and
then you're going to choose your call to
action so the whole idea behind an A B
test is you want to be able to find what
it is you want to test is that going to
be the call to action is it going to be
the messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there's lots of things you can
test with Facebook on a b testing so
it's all part of the ad setup so things
you can change again are the color of
the elements Imaging text the call to
action the position of the ad there's
lots of things you could test that's all
part of the Facebook setup so the thing
is you want to continuously test that's
the key continuously test certain
elements of an ad so testing can be done
initially on broader elements and then
smaller finer details like statements in
your ad copy so my advice is when you're
actually setting this up on Facebook you
know think ahead think what it is you
want to choose to test my advice is
maybe start out with a call to action so
if you're in Facebook itself you have an
opportunity to test different call to
action try that that's an easy way to
test and then you know when you test the
call to action once you find out what
works and doesn't work then you can move
on to something more sophisticated like
maybe the image type or maybe trying to
different types of imagery or ad types
like the carousel versus single image so
start small start easy and then work
your way up tip number seven so we want
to choose an appropriate call to action
in your advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
to Simply learn ad about hey learn how
SEO Works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the Right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interest it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know customers
and in the buying process then that's
our objectives to get conversions then
we want to move somebody over to a
product page and get them to purchase
you know if it's focusing on just
website visits then maybe it's the
objective of consideration maybe you
just want to get people to your website
to learn more about your product so
that's the whole idea behind you know
choosing uh the right you know objective
because you want to align the objective
with your ad okay so tip number nine
create look-alike audiences and I'd like
lookalike audience because what Facebook
does is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you already
advertising to or customer base you
already have so in other words Facebook
already has an idea of who your audience
is you can also you know provide them
with additional information like an
email list to give them a better sense
of who your audience is and then what
Facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
Facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have and one example provide Facebook
with an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could Target so that's
the whole idea behind look-alike
audience it's a great feature by
Facebook definitely recommend taking
advantage of that why because it will
increase the number of people who will
find your advertisement relevant
remember you're targeting people who are
similar to your actual audience to your
the people who are already connected
with your brand or already liking your
page so if they're similar to those
people then the chances of them engaging
with you are going to be greater so
look-alike audiences tend to perform
well because you're targeting an
audience that's very similar to your
actual audience tip number 10 so use the
golden Point rule on your ad creative so
what do we mean by Golden Point rule
well let's take this ad here as an
example so what we want to do is we want
to devote the creative into nine equally
sized boxes so what we want to do is
draw two horizontal lines and two
vertical lines just like a tic-tac-toe
box and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main subject of your ad in the
cross sections of the draw lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there as a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden Point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on Facebook
and this one's my blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about this
particular ad takes into account a lot
of them okay so this is again they're
using multiple and images in this ad
here so again what they're doing
promotion they're offering up a 30 off
promotion here and what they're asking
you to do is sign up to get that thirty
dollar off so you can see the call to
action we already mentioned that on one
of our tips the call to action matches
the ads so they're asking to sign up
they're using really good imagery here
and they're supporting that with you
know some good copy and text so this is
what makes this ad so good I mean who
doesn't like good looking food or tasty
food and healthy food okay so they're
definitely taking advantage of the
imagery with a promotion and with a good
call to action and so remember we want
to a B test so blue apron is likely
testing this ad so what they could do
with this is test different imagery or
they could test a different promotions
so there's a lot they can do here on the
a b testing side so for me if I were to
test this yeah I would probably be
testing the imageries because we want to
be able to see what images get people to
sign up alternatively we can also test
the offer as well what offer is going to
get somebody to click on that sign up
button so ideally there's a lot to do
here from the A B test standpoint and
the way they've structured this ad it
makes it very easy to test so that's
what makes this ad really good is shows
good imagery has a good promotion and
aligns the CTA tip number 11 so we want
to place the product in the right hand
of your creative so the right side
should contain our product imagery so
why is that why because there's been a
study called perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the ad creative so here you can see
countdown of Black Friday this is an
Amazon related ad and you could see the
product is basically a litter box which
is placed on the right side so it's a
Black Friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20 percent text okay so you
want to use images that are clean
remember that blue apron image we looked
at and that was a very clean image of
food no text overlaying the image so we
want to try and stay away from images
that have text on the overlay okay so
there's no limit to how much text you
can add to your creative but you know
Facebook and myself recommend hey the
Lesser text you have the more likely it
is for your ad to have its desired
impact meaning somebody's going to click
on that ad okay so keep that in mind let
the image do the talking for you you
don't necessarily need to overwhelm
found the image with words or messages
tip number 13 so we want to use an ad
creative that's attention grabbing and
is relevant for your business so again
going back to that blue apron ad hey who
doesn't like good looking food good
looking healthy food green food well
Switching gears we're looking at a Nike
ad who doesn't like a good looking shoe
here this is a good running shoe and
Nike is definitely taking advantage of
the opportunity to place the shoe
against a nice looking background so
here the image on the left you got a
nice mauve looking color the shoe on the
right on a nice red background to kind
of really play into the color of the
shoe and so that's attention grabbing so
the colors kind of match and go with one
another and it tends to grab your
attention so Nike's doing a good job
here of just not showing an image of a
shoe really what they're doing is put
the shoe is essential focal point and
supporting that with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe so they're making it as a tension
grabbing as possible here so Nike's done
a good job with this ad you know me
personally I'm not the biggest Nike fan
when it comes to shoes but hey this ad
definitely grabbed my attention because
now I could see you know this shoe is
really popping to me we don't want to
use clip art in your ad creative okay
and don't use low resolution pixelated
images as well we want to use high
quality imagery so and use images that
are well lit you know natural lighting
always tends to work well as as well so
when you're doing a placement for
product whether that be food or shoe you
could see here in this plated example
they're putting it on the Right image
they're putting it in a natural
environment on a table on a plate with
some paper next to it you know and then
you could see the one on the left it's
of a person holding a box with the image
of plated on it and said to me that's
not stock imagery or clip art you know
that's an actual person holding the
product so it's real life you want to
make it as real life as possible and as
clear and quality as possible so when
you create attention grabbing ads you
know show images of people benefiting
from your product instead of just having
the product itself so that's always a
good idea in the case of Coca-Cola you
know these people are enjoying their
bottle of Coca-Cola well going back to
the Nike ad you know they could have had
a person wearing that shoe or you know
running with that shoe that could have
been an alternative for them as well so
the whole idea is just make sure your
ads are attention getting and they grab
your attention and if you're going to
use people make sure the person's
enjoying it just like on the previous
image it's a person Hole In The Box we
could see she's got a smile on her face
and she is enjoying holding that box so
to me you want to use people with the
images to the best of your ability and
that means use that person who's
enjoying it so that's really going to
put the product in the Forefront okay
tip 14 don't hesitate to experiment with
your advertisements creative or its copy
okay so what do we mean by that really
we want to be refreshing our text we
want to be refreshing our images okay so
if you're going to place an ad on
Facebook don't let that be the only ad
okay if you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image from time to time
especially if a lot of people have seen
that ad so if you're using reach as your
objective and you're trying to reach as
many people as possible just keep in
mind that if that ad is reaching the
same people over and over again it's
going to get stale and you want to be
able to update that ad so feel free to
change out the imagery changing out the
tax is just as easy okay so feel free to
play around with the text even if you're
not doing a b testing you can always
change change out the text just to see
hey if changing out the text actually
gets you better engagement or meet your
goals tip 15 plan your campaigns for the
holiday season okay so can't State this
enough you know towards you know October
November December there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode so
advertisers are really pushing ads that
time of year especially Christmas you
know and people are accepting of that
because they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during Christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really really
take advantage of increasing your sales
increasing in your conversions so you
want to plan accordingly and so if
you're planning you know months in
advance you don't have to do a full year
but you know for me if I'm thinking I'm
going to do a lot of advertising during
the holiday season I'm probably going to
go out maybe once summer ends probably
August beginning of September beginning
of September seasons change a little I
might start thinking about the holiday
season and when you could plan
appropriately you can come out with
really good ads you can think about what
you want to say and so in this case you
know Target this particular ad is really
promoting Black Friday so Black Friday
is the day after Thanksgiving in the
United States and so here they're
letting you know Black Friday is here
and there's deals to be had so planning
in advance gives you an opportunity to
really really tweak your messaging and
come up with some good creative ideas so
let's take another break and let's look
at another good looking ad this example
we're going to look at well okay so Dell
I've seen their ads all over Facebook
they do a lot of different advertising
types between videos carousels again
this is a single image ad they're really
trying to do is get you over to the
storefront so you can buy one of these
good-looking you know Dell computers
okay so you know here again they're
promoting their latest computer the Dell
Inspirion 3000 Series All in One desktop
so to them anytime they create a new
product they're going to go ahead and
pull out a new ad for that product and
here they're putting a little bit of a
Different Twist on it if you notice the
ad itself it's just the image of the
product there's really no promotion here
they're letting the product image speak
for itself they're really showing you
hey look how good this computer looks
you know this is our new model and you
know we got a shop now ctas if you're
interested go ahead and click on that
shop now so they're really putting the
effort into the image itself you know
they're not offering any promotion you
know no discounts you know what you see
is what you get with the image and you
click on it you're going to go right to
their storefront so Dell does a good job
of really you know cranking out their
new products whenever they go to market
so tip 16. shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
Target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody has seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website somebody's even
purchased from you before you have the
opportunity to reach back out to that
person so how often you reach out to
that person or how long between their
initial engagement and when you retarget
them really does depend on what it is
you're selling so if you're selling a
pair of shoes if you're Nike then
chances are somebody's looking for a
pair of shoes it's not going to be a
long purchase window meaning they're not
going to wait two three months so uh if
I'm Nike and somebody's seen my ad I'm
probably gonna Target that person in a
short period of time for retargeting so
it really depends on your product but
you don't want to wait too long between
the time they've been initially engaged
and the time you retarget so really
depends on your product you know again
if you're selling merchandise you know
retail it's probably going to be a
smaller time frame if your Dell
computers you know that's a bigger
purchase somebody's going to take their
time so you know you want to Target
people you know for the Dell computer
probably you know over a longer period
of time okay so just keep the product in
mind you don't want to wait too long you
don't want to keep it too short so you
want to find that nice balance of when
you could recharget someone okay tip
number 17 keep altering the hook of your
ad copy what do we mean by altering the
hook so here you can see a couple of
different options option one you know
we're talking about hey if you're
interested and getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey to get your DMC CA certification
so you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody is really
what we're after here on tip number 17.
you have an ad especially the text
remember we always want to refresh that
copy but if you're testing it try
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different Hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for a
b testing okay you have an option to add
messaging go ahead and talk one way and
one option and then you know tweak that
messaging tweak that hook a bit in
option b and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for a b
testing is all always you know look at
the way you're going to try and you know
get somebody to convert tip number 18
okay respond to lead ad responses as
soon as possible so remember one of your
ad formats is a lead ad okay so if you
have a lead ad basically what you're
asking somebody to do is add their name
their phone number and their email if
you get that information don't sit on it
react to it just like the messaging the
Facebook Messenger how it's almost
instantaneous think of the lead ads the
same way okay you have somebody who's
engaging with your ad by providing
information you don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage with
that person let them know you're
available on Facebook Messenger so they
can actually then reach out to you via
Facebook Messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer want to continue
interacting with you so there's no real
good rule of thumb here except for do it
as soon as possible okay tip number 19
add scarcity to your advertisements so
what do we mean by that well in this
example we could see the top 100
registrations get free access so by
putting this into your ad copy we're
hoping your prospects are more inclined
to buy your product due to that there
that they're not going to be one of the
first 100 registrations okay so it
allows you to really put some sense of
urgency in the ad to get somebody to
react and so that's what we mean by you
know scarcity okay so by doing so it
could affect the long-term credibility
you know we don't want to come across as
fear-mongering by any means but hey if
your promotion is the first 100
registrations get free access then why
not you know go ahead and put it in
there some other examples could be you
know only three days days left to
register or first 50 get 50 off for you
know hurry now there's only two days
left so there's other language you can
put to play around with the language but
if you only have certain slots available
or certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevant scores so your ads do get
scored so the score ranges from one to
ten okay so what that score does is it's
an indicator to signify the quality and
engagement levels so you know if your
score is between one and six then the ad
isn't reaching the relevant audience and
your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your relevant score is
between seven and ten then your ads are
reaching the appropriate audience and
you're getting a lot of interaction so
keep an eye on that you know the lower
the number that means hey we're not gay
our ads not getting to the Right
audience and if it's not getting into
the Right audience our audience isn't
going to react to it so it all starts
with making sure you're reaching your
audience with your ad when your ad is
reaching your audience and you're doing
a b testing your audience is going to
react to one of those two ads so that's
always going to help your relevant score
so keep an eye on that relevant score
okay so let's take another break here
and let's take a look at an ad here by
Blue Bottle Coffee okay so I'm a big
coffee drinker myself I frequent blue
bottle in San Francisco a lot and so
here this is a nice image a nice
close-up image of coffee and I really
like this notice there's really no call
to action here okay so they're putting
their website URL the domain main
bluebottlecoffee.com they're saying hey
we Source great coffees we roast them to
Perfection and get them to you fresh so
I can vouch for that really putting
their brand out there okay so this is
more of a brand awareness type app
that's their objective their objective
is if you're going to drink coffee at
some other location or with some other
brand hey take a look at ours you know
we got good coffee too we roast them
pretty good and and we make sure that
you get them fresh that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to introduce
their brand to you so this is a good
example of a brand awareness ad single
image ad they're definitely making use
of the added the image itself you know
with a nice close-up shot of that
roasted coffee so that's what makes this
ad so special brand awareness you know
the image is telling us hey this coffee
looks pretty pretty good it looks nice
and roasted it looks pretty fresh and
maybe I'll get Blue Bottle Coffee try so
that's why they're putting their domain
there okay so it's a good brand
awareness ad and the hope is to convert
some people over to their brand okay so
tip number 21 include emojis in your ad
copy okay so emojis we know are popular
you use them in text use them on social
media I mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the case of Simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course with simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emojis support
that that message so you always get the
thumbs up so get emoji you know the
image of the graduation you know that's
a good Emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun relevant
Emojis with your messaging it kind of
just helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with Emojis and so it doesn't
hurt to add those emojis in your ad copy
and especially if you're competition is
not using emojis you want every
Advantage you can to have your ad stick
out so emojis is a good way to get your
ad to stick out tip number 22 use UTM
parameters to your ad which can feed
into your Google analytics account and
provide tracking information so I can't
stress this enough if you're using
Google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use UTM parameters so
what do we mean by UTM parameters well
let me show you an example so all you
need to do is type in UTM tracking or
URL builder in Google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create UTM tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to advertise
and drive the audience to a specific
page in this case artificial
intelligence master's program page so
this is going to be the URL but we want
to append that URL with some UTM
tracking parameters our campaign Source
parameter we're going to put Facebook
because that's the source of what we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
Facebook is CPC which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name AI engineer to
identify what it is that campaign is
related to so notice that the only
required parameters campaign Source in
this case we're going to put Facebook
but we can also use campaign content if
we want a different shape the different
ads that we have so you can use campaign
content parameter as well you don't have
to the only required parameters campaign
Source my recommendation go all
lowercase okay and then when you're done
you have a URL that you can use in your
advertising so when somebody actually
goes to that URL notice the URL includes
the UTM tracking and then analytics is
going to be able to pick up that
campaign from where Facebook the medium
is going to be CPC and the campaign in
this case is going to be AI engineer and
that's what you're going to look for in
Google analytics so it helps you track
your ads more closely because if you
don't use UTM tracking for example on
Facebook then analytics might you know
interpret that traffic coming from that
ad as you know organic social so we want
to be able to identify specifically the
campaign you're running by putting in
different variables for those parameters
so that's what UTM tracking is you want
to use it for all your Facebook
advertising okay so it really helps you
you know in analytics identify how your
campaign's performing not only is it
driving traffic but is the campaign
converting for you so if you're trying
to get somebody to sign up for a class
then analytics is going to help us
measure those conversions but with UTM
tracking we can bridge the gap between
how many people Facebook delivered or
drove to our site from the ad and how
many of those people people actually
converting so UTM parameters help bridge
that Gap tip 23 use exclusion marketing
to improve your Facebook return on
investment by not including people who
have already taken the action desired by
you okay so this is a very key feature
here so if we've already advertised and
people have reacted to our ad and has
subscribed they have subscribed then we
don't want to Target that person again
so that's what exclusion marketing is we
want to be able to you know Target
people that we're really after so if you
know somebody's looked at our ad and did
not convert or did not go to our website
or to not download something or whatever
it is we wanted them to do then those
are the people we wanted to focus in on
okay so in this case exclusion marketing
we're going to exclude people who have
subscribed in this case we're going to
retarget people meaning advertise again
to people who have not subscribed so
that's what the exclusion marketing
feature does it helps you really hone in
on where you're targeting and
retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrics for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics what are those
metrics you know those are going to be
kpis kpis or key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like uh Blue
Bottle Coffee did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your kpi or metric is going to be
a click okay or click-through rate how
many people are actually reacting to our
ad okay so you all always want to align
the right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads CPC helps us
determine the cost Effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information in your
Facebook ad manager for example if I go
to Facebook's ads manager here I'm
looking at some some ads that we're
running here what can I see I could see
my reach how many people I'm actually
reaching the frequency in which they're
seeing my ad notice I can see my
relevancy score I can also see my cost
per result I could see the total clicks
so I have a whole set of metrics
available to me really what I want to do
is pick and choose the metrics that are
most important to the ad I'm running
okay so if it's reached am I reaching
the full amount of people possible if
I'm running a brand awareness campaign
or it could be some other metric like
conversion so we want to be able to
align the right metric with the right ad
tip 25 take advantage of Facebook's
location tracking tool for your
advertisements so Facebook allows us to
advertise at up to 25 countries with
different states provinces cities
districts and zip codes so we can really
hone in location wise on where we want
to Target so Facebook allows us to do
that so basically it could be somebody
in a particular area or people who have
been recently been there or traveling to
that location or actually lived there so
really you can hone in on a specific
location based on certain set of
criteria so with this you could take
your marketing to the next level by
approaching your competitors customers
by by offering them better discounts so
that's the whole idea targeting your
advertising on a specific location and
then knowing that your competitors are
there you can really put out some really
good ads with some really good offers to
really convert some of those people in
that audience okay let's take a a look
at another ad okay so grammarly this is
an ad that they've put out there and
again you notice there's no real true
call to action associated with a single
image ad here it's all about messaging
here they're saying hey download it free
today okay and so it's a browser
extension that they're promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify with this
particular brand that offers a specific
product so they do have a promotion in
there it's brand awareness hey your life
is about to change I mean the messaging
is pretty you know matter of fact
they're trying to get you to hey I need
this in my browser as an extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here okay so with grammarly
you know if you're in Gmail you're in
word you're an Outlook they got you
covered by using their browser expansion
it's free and by using it it's going to
make your life a lot easier so for me
the ad works from a messaging standpoint
not really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and we
can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention how to rank YouTube
videos today so it's simply learn we
take our videos on YouTube very
seriously meaning that when we create
videos we want people to see them
because we know we make good videos and
we know we have good content and we know
that our audience is going to enjoy it
and so we want our audience to see the
videos that we're creating and so we're
going to give you some tips and tricks
and methodology and ideas on how to get
your videos to rank on YouTube so at
simply learn if I go to YouTube and I
just type in machine learning you could
see where right here is the first
organic video on YouTube for machine
learning if I jump over to Google and I
type in machine learning Basics you can
see where number or number one from
machine learning Basics under videos if
I click on all we're also ranked here as
well under the video section on organic
search results another example data
science for beginners we ranked number
one for that if I look at another
keyword data science interview questions
okay we're rank number two for that so
we're ranking for a lot of videos and
why are we ranking for a lot of
different content and videos on Google
Search and on YouTube well we put a lot
of work in behind the scenes of creating
the video and that's what we want to
show you so part of that has a lot to do
with you know how our audience engages
and sees our video so for example we're
looking at the machine learning Basics
video here and we can see that it has
over 221 000 subscribers for this video
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of Engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on YouTube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share it you want people to like it
you want people to comment on that and
that's part of the whole ecosystem of
YouTube It's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos to the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning Basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people you use YouTube search
every day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're gonna go into a few things to
do here to find the right keywords so we
have the search suggestion you can look
at your competitors we have different
tools we can use some other factors
involved in Google itself so let's start
talking about some of these ways to
really hone in and do some good research
on your keywords to align them with your
videos so first thing is search suggest
so YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine machine learning
tutorial so here you can see simply
learns rank number one for machine
learning tutorial but there are other
videos that show up in my search result
so we want to be able to use the search
suggestion box in the search box field
so when we're typing in something new
YouTube just like on Google is going to
give us those suggestions so if we're
focusing a video on machine learning
then you know we have some ideas of some
other keywords that we could center
around because these are are popular
keywords these are key words that people
are using to search on YouTube so that's
one suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title description and then once you do
that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way to go back so here
I can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the key words associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas it's the most popular
keywords so if they're related align
those keywords with the video so here
you can see Facebook marketing Facebook
ad strategy Facebook ads for beginners
so forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right click in view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you could see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
it gives you those keyword ideas looking
at your competitors videos also gives
you some other ideas for keywords that
you can align with a video that's
relevant that you want to rank for so
let's look at some other ideas here so
you can install plugins and there are
plenty of plugins available on the
Chrome browser that will help you see
the video tags associated with a
particular video so a couple of examples
are vid IQ and tubebuddy those are
extensions that work in Chrome and what
they do is they give you the exact tags
that a particular video is using so for
example if I go back here and I look at
a video on YouTube let's just say the
machine learning Basics video I have vid
IQ installed on my Chrome browser so
just by clicking on that vid IQ is going
to give me a lot of information about
that video I'm just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information Nation associated with
Facebook some engagement metrics really
what I'm interested in is those keywords
so if I scroll down a bit here I can see
the video tags associated with the
machine learning Basics video so vid IQ
is telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's enough other way for you to
really get an understanding of what
keywords to use at the particular video
so autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitors video or you can
use a Chrome extension in this case I'm
using vid IQ to give me some information
about the video tags for a particular
video so according to an industry study
using keywords and video tags will help
you rank well on YouTube so you have to
use keywords and video tags if you want
your video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance that
out with keywords that have low
difficulty and are easier to rank for so
you don't want to choose something very
broad that's just going to be very
difficult to rank for and of course we
always want to go with relevancy so for
talking about machine learning Basics
then we want to choose keywords
associated with that and that's where
that autocomplete comes in handy because
what Google's going to do and YouTube's
going to do is give us keywords that are
very closely related to the video that
we're trying to optimize for and so we
have a number of different keywords that
are disposal that are relevant that we
can look to see if they have good volume
and low competition and so the whole
idea is we want to choose a keyword that
defines the nature of the content and
then what we want to do is support that
with secondary keywords so we want
keywords that are highly relevant to the
primary keyword so that's the way to go
about aligning your keywords you want
keywords that are high volume low
competition or relevant and you want to
choose that one keyword that is really
what the content's about and then those
secondary keywords that support the
primary so if you have a machine
learning video you could choose your
primary keyword as in this case the
machine learning Basics video so well
chosen keywords help you rank well on
YouTube to just like the machine
learning Basics so if I go back to our
video our machine learning Basics video
if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from is
well aligned because it's in the title
it's in the copy and it's a line is a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction and machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary a keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning and introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google shows on the
video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
so if I go back to Google and I just
type in data science for beginners and I
type in videos then you can see we're
ranked number one so even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular key word and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to say signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so much machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so takes into
account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if I go
back to you know search here we can see
the you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember clicked array is clicks divided
by Impressions and an impression is how
many times your video shows up and the
search results on YouTube or Google so
we want to keep our click-through rate
high and in order to do that we want to
be able to write some really good title
tags for our video so use catchy words
like a number or how to or what is
because that's going to resonate with
people when they're searching now for
the description what we want to do is we
want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if I go back to
my video here machine learning Basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube let's turn our
attention to creating high quality
videos and some of the best practices
around that so along with everything we
mentioned about choosing the right
keywords we always need to keep in mind
that the videos we create need to be of
high quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords is a primary
factor in ranking so in order to have
keywords we need to have content and in
order to rank we need to have you know
good content so let's talk a little bit
about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or irrelevant to the topic
it won't rank so that's just common
sense so you need to create content
that's aligned with the topic obviously
and then that way you have keywords that
are in line with the content so but if
you have content and it really isn't
aligned with the topic then you're not
going to rank no matter how much you've
optimized that video so just keep that
in mind so there's a couple of things we
want to look at here so high quality
content is determined by really two
metrics so for not sure about how good
our content is and how good of a high
quality video we created we want to look
at audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention is
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched It's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched and for example it
can be both absolute and min minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so yours engagement
of viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that region is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recommendation mission is
you know create an outline first and
once you create an outline of how the
video is going to flow then start
populating with content and so to me
that's how you can keep the flow
organized okay is really with an outline
starting out with an on how there's no
videos are no different than say a
presentation if you've done a PowerPoint
presentation you always want to start
out doing an outline then we want to
upload a high resolution videos high
resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know a small resolution
like say you know 400 by 400 resolution
or something you know something really
small we want to create something a very
high res so according to back or link
Oaks more than 50 of videos on the first
page of YouTube are high definition so
high definition videos of higher quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of YouTube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos or examples of
creating high quality video we also want
to make sure that content is relevant to
the title so if we're talking about
machine learning Basics you know
obviously the content is going to be
about you know intro to machine learning
or what is machine learning and then the
title should reflect that content so
aligning the title sets the expectation
for the end user so when they see a
title what is machine learning then when
they watch the video they're expecting
to learn about machine learning and what
it is so if it meets expectations then
the chances are that person who's
watching the video is going to watch it
longer and that means it's going to
fulfill the viewers requirements and
when you align everything accordingly
keywords titles content then at the end
of the day the user is going to watch it
and the more they watch it the higher
the engagement the higher the engagement
the better chance you have to rank some
other tips that you could use to create
great high quality videos so we want to
be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you know don't be
afraid to go into another screen like I
am if I want to I'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning Basics
video which I've done throughout this
session I can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning Basics well the
title is online with the video we made
sure that we have a nice description
about what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that I'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like Shutterstock
or flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the the subject matter expert
when creating the video create it with
your own original content have high
audio quality and video effects so just
like you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content that
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content go along with the video that
outline I referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
Content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video okay focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out
altogether so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in YouTube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
43 44 watch the video for at least two
minutes here I can see 28 points six
percent wash it for six minutes plus so
that's the audience retention it gives
us an idea in terms of percentage how
many people or percentage of people
watch the video at what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all best practices
to keep the viewer engaged and then we
want to add resources from well-known
sites so throughout this video we've
used backlinko there are other sources
we've used so if you have a source go
ahead and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or you too can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
want a hundred percent of the video the
video is seven minutes long if almost
half of our audience saw over half of
the video then I would say that's pretty
good people were engaged so audience
retention just is a good report to start
looking at to help you understand how
engaging is my video and if your video
is not engaging you know you can always
go back and edit it or fix it or tweak
it so remember the average view duration
for all videos and top performing videos
listed by all time we can look at that
information as well in addition we can
look at demographics so we can get an
overview of the age gender and location
and we can look at playback locations
report and what the playback locations
report does is it helps us determine the
platforms where our videos are being
streamed from within YouTube look at the
traffic sources where did the viewers
come from devices did they look on
mobile or tablet and so so if there's
any doubts you know if you have any
questions please drop a comment below
but especially if you have any doubts on
the metrics so if we go back into
YouTube we can look at analytics and if
we're looking at analytics we can see
more and then this is going to show us
everything we need to see from device
type so if I click on more I can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video is watched it was on a
watch page or a channel page I could see
the traffic sources I could see the
gender and age so if I click on the
viewer age report I can see the
percentage of views by age so I can get
a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you published to
YouTube high quality align with your
keywords you're going to be able to view
the metrics by looking at YouTube
analytics so let's talk about the
importance of user engagement so
engagement is as we mentioned important
because something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 1080 pixel size okay
that's HD and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that it's probably going to come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry not professional not high def so
you want to create a high def video and
1080 is about the minimum you want to go
and then you want to plan your video
script before filming so it goes back to
some of the other points I made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
Fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professionals so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump Cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to accentuate your points and
then set up a green background for
recording again this is for you know
making sure that the video part of it
comes across in good quality and
stabilize your video recordings with a
tripod that way you're not moving your
video camera around and again it's
coming across the shaky and poor quality
shoot horizontal videos you don't want
to go vertical it tends to cut the
screen so you want to stay horizontal so
that people can see everything that
should be included in the video okay you
want to capture a wider shot using a
clip-on lens again a good feature a good
tip to use use that wider shot okay so
you could do that using a clip-on lens
and then choose good video editing
software I can't State this enough
because you're putting all this time and
effort into a video you need to be able
to edit it to cut out you know some of
the things you didn't want to say or
maybe some poor quality or or you know
you just want to have a smooth
professional output for your video and
so you gotta have good video editing
software there's plenty of options
available on the internet again I would
go with something low cost but paid
usually free isn't exactly the way you
want to go if you're trying to create a
high def good quality video and at the
very least review your work before
publishing I just said it a minute ago
I'll say it again you want to be able to
have a really professional video and
high def when you have a good
professional video in high def with good
audio horizontal shots you know nice
green background image nice well lit
it's going to come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are going
to take you seriously they're going to
see you as a professional and then share
or subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're gonna have to do it all
over again so follow these tips get a
high quality video and you should be on
your way to ranking in fact according to
backlinko YouTube preferably ran ranks
HD videos so you gotta have that 1080
pixel size that way you know your video
is going to come across crisp and clear
and YouTube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber Watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in YouTube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
Watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your Channel The Watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your YouTube account it's it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're going to select your creator
Studio icon and then you're going to go
to channel select branding and then add
a watermark to your video so if we look
at that in YouTube so here Creator
Studio on the left side navigation I'm
just going to click Channel then I'm
going to click branding and then once
you click Brandon you have the ability
to add your watermark and then you can
add it to the entire video at the end of
the video at a specific start time and
then just click update and that's pretty
much it so you want to be able to add
this so that you can brand your videos
with an image and then add that CTA so
this is a good good feature for YouTube
it allows you to be consistent with all
your videos by branding and adding that
call to action tip 7 engage with your
audience so you want to be able to
interact with your audience as much as
possible just because the video and you
can't see people doesn't mean you can't
engage with them so when you interact
with your viewers especially when you
interact with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of every busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with YouTube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other other ways to engage
with your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on YouTube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback there's always going to be
positive some of the feedback could be
less than positive or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback is you want to
look at it you want to read it and you
want to react to it you want to react to
it positively in the form of you know
what thank you for the feedback and
looking at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback so you don't
always want to make the same mistake
twice in a video so if there's something
definitely wrong with the video that
we're doing for example and somebody
looked at it and gave us feedback on it
we'd certainly definitely take a deep
look into that and try not to do the
same mistake twice because likely that
user is going going to watch the video
again so you always want to learn from
your mistakes and you want to turn those
mistakes or turn those comments into
future videos okay so create videos
based on your commenter's request the
audience has given us feedback we should
take that as positive and sometimes
that's creative sometimes those ideas
for more videos okay you always want to
ask questions to your audience and
reward excellent commenters so we try to
ask questions in our videos and when
users respond with the answer if there's
an excellent comment or excellent answer
you know we can reward them you know
reward them in the form of say some type
of gift card or gift certificate or
promotion or something there's always
some way to incentivize somebody who
provides excellent feedback you can
always give Emoji Hearts there's so many
emojis out there that you can use emojis
just to engage with your audience based
on the feedback that they're giving the
point is if your audience is taking the
time to give feedback you always want to
respond to it and you want to respond to
a positive so emojis tend to have a
positive connotation to them and so
responding with an emoji especially to a
favorite comment goes a long way so you
can reward your community both on and
off YouTube for their engagement and
support and that's just being creative
you can reward in many ways many ways
not necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
YouTube has them other platforms like
Facebook have them Instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flash so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers and subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can Captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
YouTube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and and get
their videos and use their videos and
upload them to your channel so according
to backlinko video comments of a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey if you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video I see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and I'm gonna ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
YouTube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your YouTube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how you can use different
platforms so the first thing you want to
do is look at the platforms you're
already using if you're using Facebook
and Instagram that's probably a good
place to start but there's other
platforms you can also Leverage we're
going to talk about those so social
media most companies most individuals
are on in some form or fashion amongst
the most popular like Facebook and
Instagram so you can start there so with
Facebook you can post something include
the link of your YouTube video with
Facebook if you're a business you have a
business page you're communicating with
your community and that's a great way to
get started by promoting your YouTube
video you can also do the same on
Twitter or Instagram or whatever
platform you're on go ahead and post
something or tweet something and include
that link to YouTube you can participate
in forums and blog discussions so
there's plenty of forums and blogs out
there where you can participate in
discussion and include a link to the
YouTube video if it's relevant and
natural so for example here there's a
Blog about machine learning you can
include if you have a video about
machine learning and the response to
that conversation in this example we've
done that on Reddit yeah you can list
your video and relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimony and
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here touchgenics okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for AWS so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating it backlink for
us not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your YouTube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like Gmail or Yahoo or even Hotmail or
Outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to your YouTube channel it doesn't
have to be to a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your YouTube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your Audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community pitch and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free very little time to do this but
it's a chance for you to get the video
out there and even generate a backlink
you can collaborate with other YouTube
channels this is always a good strategy
if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on YouTube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their Channel
and you can take their video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other YouTube channels is swap videos
you could join High PR QA sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or ehab okay so core there's always a
question of being posted and if you have
the answer to that question in the form
of your video then go ahead and post a
response with a link to the video on
YouTube it's a great way to get the
video noticed and it's relevant and
natural okay you can embed videos in
your blog posts or if you're using a
platform like WordPress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post I like this option I think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text Heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video in your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you can promote other videos in your
end screen for example at the end of
your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use them in email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumble upon you
know collaborate with other people on
YouTube you know go to core respond to a
question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're gonna get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video If
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so with Twitter it's all about tweets
it's actually a verb now uh when you do
something on Twitter you actually tweet
and there are a lot of people out there
tweeting in fact Twitter has over 1.3
billion accounts so a lot of tweets
going on in the world of Twitter so as
of the third quarter in 2018 last year
Twitter had 326 million Global monthly
active users okay so active meaning
every day using the platform on a daily
basis so a lot of people using Twitter
it's very easy to use as you'll find out
and what you're going to find out today
is how to increase followers on your
Twitter account so they can see more of
your tweets okay a little bit more about
Twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information be
disseminated across the plan platform so
tweets with videos so Twitter does a lot
of videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our YouTube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding Facebook or
Instagram you'll know that videos do
perform better Twitter is no exception
so if you have a video even if it's done
on YouTube or if it's not unpublished on
YouTube use it with Twitter you're going
to get more engagement so Twitter has 75
percent of its users use the platform
for news Okay so people go to Twitter to
get their news that's where they go they
don't go to a regular website
content-based website they get their
news via Twitter it's just very easy to
digest because it's so few characters 75
of B2B businesses Market on Twitter so
not only is it a b2c or business to
Consumer platform it's a B2B business to
business platform so a lot of businesses
are on Twitter basically promoting
either a product service or trying to
establish themselves in the industry
using the platform so let's take a look
at Twitter and let's take a look at some
of the ways in which you can increase
your followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the Twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
Twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
Twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a key word friendly bio
okay a link to your website and a
picture that represents your brand
always helps so make sure it's is
complete you can even take a step
further by customizing the color scheme
of your profile you can add a header
image that sticks to your theme that
will help your profile stand out and so
let's take a look at an example here so
if I go to Twitter here if we go to
Simply learn it's Twitter account okay
their handle is simply at simply learn
okay they've customized the header they
use their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pic here where they're
based a little bit about them so just uh
you know customize complete profile goes
a long way you don't have to go
overboard with an elaborate design so to
speak but just make it stand out make it
associate with who you are as a person
and a brand those are best practices in
getting that profile up and running you
don't want to use something Bland and
generic you know take the extra step
create something unique make sure your
profile is unique you have a good image
okay make sure it's complete with of you
know telling people who you are and what
you're all about that's really the first
step on really any social media platform
so you want to promote your Twitter
profile to drive users from other social
media platforms so when you actually get
that Twitter account set up and you
actually do have your handle go ahead
and share it that's the first step in
getting followers if you're already on
Facebook if you're already on Instagram
then use those platforms to announce
that you're on Twitter you can also take
that a step further and you know send
out an email to friends or family or
like I said if you're on Facebook go
ahead and set up a post say hey guys I'm
on Twitter you know come follow me so
you can also use business cards
advertisements marketing materials and
events to put that Twitter profile on
okay so it doesn't have to be within the
social media sphere it could be even on
your website it can be even in email so
you can basically promote that profile
again you want to make that profile that
handle easy to remember so so totally
real person is the profile in this
example we're going to use that profile
everywhere we can whether that be
offline or online you don't don't be
afraid to use it on a business card
especially if it's easy I can just
simply go to Twitter and type in that
handle so you want to stay active on
Twitter with regular retweets replies
and favorites and that's just it's just
so easy to retreat and reply and add
favorites so let's take a look at that
on Twitter so you could just simply I'm
logged in as me and if I want to retweet
something that simply learned did I can
just simply click on the retweet button
and I can add a comment if I want to and
then I'm going to retweet it's that
simple so now that tweet is going to
show up on my profile my handle and I
could simply like it if I scroll down
here okay top 10 it Trends shaping 2019
notice a simple tweet supported with an
image so I'm just gonna like that so I
can even comment on on it I can click on
the comment and click a reply here okay
and that's going to show up in this
tweet here just like if I click on this
I'll be able to see what other people
have written and so it's that simple if
I want I can just click on the email
button and even send a message to
somebody right from that tweet the point
is I can do everything I need to do
right in the platform but to get started
if you don't have any tweets you know go
and find other companies similar to you
look at their tweeting and you can
always retweet that that's a good way to
get going with tweaks that's what I
started doing when I started on Twitter
in 2008 I didn't know what to write
particularly and I didn't know how to
write it particularly well so I looked
at what other people wrote and and
tweeted and just retweeted those that's
a good way to get your Twitter account
started okay so engaging with users is a
great way to get more followers so on
simply learn I retweeted one of their
tweets I liked another one of their
tweets and it's probably gonna get their
attention somebody at simply learn is
going to say okay Rob Sanders went ahead
and liked us and you know what we're
gonna go follow this guy he seems to be
somebody who's an audience member who
likes what we have to do likes what we
have to say like what we're tweeting
let's go ahead and follow him and so
that's a good way to get going with your
Twitter account is to really start
retweeting and liking other tweets from
other users so you can find an
appropriate time to post your tweets to
increase exposure retweets and followers
and you want to do this you could do it
within Twitter or as I'll mention later
you can do it in a social media platform
like Sprout social or HootSuite or later
or buffer and there's plenty of social
media platforms out there for you to
schedule tweets point is you want to be
able to schedule those tweets when it's
the appropriate time so you don't want
to do it in the middle of the evening
because what's going to happen is likely
by the morning other tweets are going to
bury your Tweet so you want to be able
to find the appropriate time to post
your tweets so according to a survey
conducted by HubSpot the best time to
post is between 12 and 3 P.M and why is
that well most people are usually on
lunch check in their phones yes Twitter
has an app and in fact most people use
the app just like on Instagram just like
on YouTube the app is very popular on
Twitter so it's very easy for somebody
to check tweets especially during the
lunch hour and then from 5 to 6 p.m that
that in between time when when people
are wrapping up work or heading home
okay so weekdays have shown to have the
maximum amount of Engagement so during
the week when people are working highly
engaged with whatever they're doing
depending on what industry you're in
they're likely going to check the
Twitter and react during those times
okay so that was a survey conducted by
hotspot but really what you want to do
is you want to be able to use one of
these social media platforms like a
HootSuite or lay later and find out
exactly when are people engaging with
your tweets when I what time of the day
what day of the week are you getting the
most retweets or the most likes okay
that's what you want to do so you can
use this as a starting point as a best
practice but eventually you're gonna
have to cater to your audience based on
when you're getting your tweets engaged
so you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple let me
rephrase that so it really is that
simple so if I go back to Twitter you
know Twitter's always going to recommend
somebody for me to follow and normally
those are people that are similar as
myself okay so they're not just going to
choose random people they're going to
choose people who are following people
you're following so there's going to be
a connection to some degree or they
could be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so you want to
go ahead and follow people the rule of
thumb on Twitter is if you follow
somebody on Twitter chances are they're
going to follow you back you know I was
once told when I was using Twitter that
hey you want to give somebody about
three days to follow you back so that's
always what the rule I stuck to you know
wait about three days start following
people you can see here 833 people that
or accounts Twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over ten thousand
nine hundred followers to Simply learn's
Twitter account so for me I don't mind
having a nice balance myself I have just
as many followers as I do following and
that's a good thing so because you want
to be able to keep up with what people
are tweeting and so you can retweet at
the same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your Twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are following dollars
of your followers and you can use
Twitter's who to follow list and upload
your email contacts to Twitter okay
since they know you they're more likely
to follow you back okay so you can use
Twitter's who to follow list and so if
we go back to Twitter here's the who to
follow list and so this is what Twitter
is going to recommend but you can click
on this link here find people you know
okay so if I click on find people I know
then I can upload my contacts from
Outlook or Gmail and they're gonna find
people who are already on Twitter based
on who I'm connected with so generally
that's how it works that's a quick way
to get more followers is to connect with
people you know by the way I'm going to
follow simply learn because I wasn't
following them prior so now I just
clicked on the follow button now I am
following so now I'm going to see simply
learns Tweets in my feed so let's take a
second to look at a brand okay so it's
time for a brand watch let's have a look
at some of the the best Tweets of 2018.
now remember there are a lot of active
users millions of active users that's a
lot of tweets so what we did was we
scoured Twitter from 2018 and we went
ahead and picked out some tweets that we
thought were pretty good and so the
first one is Wendy's now I don't know if
any of you have actually eaten at
Wendy's I used to eat at Wendy's a while
ago I know their frosties are pretty
good so what they've done is they
Incorporated that Frosty as part of a
giveaway okay so basically they're
saying hey grab yourself a free Frosty
with any purchase in our app so they're
encouraging people to use our app and
then they're following that up by saying
hey and then join us on Twitch from two
to five eastern as we unlock all that
Frosty goodness so they're promoting
something that's going to happen on a
specific point in time this is of last
January they're encouraging people to
use their app and they're using that
Frosty as kind of a carrot if you will
okay is a catch it's a giveaway so they
were able to you know basically wrap a
bunch of things into one so get
encourage people to take part and I'm
sure a lot of people went ahead and took
part of this but we could definitely see
that 206 retweeted this tweet 302
basically commented on it and over 3 000
liked the Tweet so the Tweet was good
and it basically engaged with users who
doesn't like a free giveaway especially
free frosting so that's why this
particular tweet really does some
justice for the target audience Their
audience they're they're giving
something away to Their audience just by
allowing them to you know use their app
okay so this tweet combines a lot into
one and I like it apparently a lot more
people than I did 3000 plus also like
this tweet and so moving on to how to
increase your followers on Twitter you
want to mention other people in your
tweets to increase engagement so what do
we mean by that so let's look at Twitter
here so go back if we look at simply
learn just take a look at some of their
tweets what they're doing if we scroll
down here they have hashtags so they are
mentioning specific hashtags but you can
also mention handles as well so the
hashtag is always going to start with
either pound sign but if we scroll down
here if you use the at symbol you're
actually mentioning somebody so in this
case we're mentioning Matt Bailey so
Matt Bailey says is Matt Bailey's handle
and so if you get a shout out to
somebody they're gonna pick up on that
and then they're going to probably
follow you okay who doesn't appreciate
getting recognized for something
especially something as small as a tweet
okay notice I can go ahead and click
follow if I want to follow my bailey but
it's not a bad idea to add people into
your Tweet and you simply do that by
just using the at symbol and using their
Twitter handle it's a good way to get
recognized by that Twitter follower it
also increases engagement because it's
adding validity to the tweet and it
definitely catches the attention of the
person mentioned remember if you use
that person's handle they're going to
see that that you mention them okay and
what it's likely going to do is start
some type of Twitter relationship okay
they're gonna then follow you you're
gonna follow them and chances of them
retweeting you in the future or
mentioning you in the future is probably
going to increase and overall that
increases engagement so another
important thing you want to do is find
and use hashtags that are relevant to
your brand and audience so this is a
must this is mandatory on Twitter you
need to use hashtags Twitter's all about
hashtags every tweet that goes out
should have a hashtag team so what you
can do is figure out what hashtags are
trending so here what Twitter does is it
trends for you so these are all specific
hashtags that are trending it's Mother's
Day Happy Mother hey Sunday morning
whatever works for you these are trends
that happen to be moving meaning a lot
of people are using them clicking on
them okay so you can use a popular
hashtag what I would also recommend is
you use a unique hashtag the rule of
thumb is usually about two hashtags in a
tweet but that's a rule of thumb but
rules are made to be broken do what's
best for you if you want to include more
than two hashtags go for it the only
thing I'm recommending is include a
hashtag so find out what's trending you
could just look right in Twitter or you
could just create your own unique
hashtag it works both ways but when you
have a hashtag in your Tweet and
somebody clicks on it then they're going
to go to that particular handle that
hashtag and so when they look at the
hashtag you're going to see all the
tweets with that hashtag in it so that's
the idea behind hashtags you want to
have hashtags okay so if somebody clicks
on a hashtag that you've used then
they're likely going to see your Tweet
in that hashtags feed okay so that's how
hashtags work you want to use hashtags
okay but you want to use hashtags that
are relevant to your branded audience
that's really the key so hashtags help
your tweets to be found through Twitter
search thus improving your reach and
increase the visibility of your post so
that's another benefit Twitter has
search functionality so somebody can
simply go in and start searching on
Twitter so if I go back to Twitter I can
just do a hashtag and start typing in
something like Spanish and I'm gonna get
some of the most popular Spanish
hashtags or Hashtags with the word
Spanish in it and so this is an idea for
me that if I wanted to use a hashtag
with Spanish in it these are some ideas
but they're certainly searchable on
Twitter okay so if I just click on
Spanish okay I'm going to be able to see
all the Hashtags with the word Spanish
in the hashtag so definitely use
hashtags it's the most beneficial
feature of Twitter Bar None So some
reasons why using in hashtags also a
good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your Tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
Their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on Twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the Tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know I work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good Twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if I wanted to be just like
simply learn well I could simply just go
to their Twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag so what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so I can simply just
click on the 10 900 followers that they
have and what I could do is I can go
through and start following the people
that are following them so just mimic
your competition to some degree or mimic
others in the industry you know look at
what they're tweeting again start out by
retweeting some of the stuff they're
retweeting if it's good stuff if it's
like a tweet don't be afraid to retweet
even your competitors tweets okay use
unique hashtags use the hashtags they're
using look at who's following their
brand so you can really learn a lot from
others in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people whose
follow them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets gets some sense of what they're
doing and again when I say mimic I mean
what I'm saying is pull best practices
from that Twitter account this will give
you an idea what you need to do to get
more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
Twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow Bill Gates or Elon Musk
or Richard Branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer who has an
influence on a lot of people okay but
make sure they're in your industry
that's the key if you can make sure
they're in your industry and you follow
them chances are if they look at your
Twitter account and see you're posting
or maybe retweeting some of their tweets
they're likely to follow you and if
they're following you your tweets are
going to show up on their handle on
their feed and so don't be afraid to go
out and connect and follow those
influencers it's a good way to boost up
your followers so again this will help
you gain followers since you can
replicate what they've done with their
profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mine so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their posts so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock Photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from Simply learn so
if I click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that Matt Bailey was at so it was a
retweet from Matt Bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learns doing is they're including either
a video or they're including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
image in your tweets can help you gain
more than a hundred and fifty percent
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an Arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
Snowball Effect just by using images
Okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay Pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars I
like pizza here the this just says it
all you know they're talking about art
and they're using Pizza in the form of
art so they didn't really have to say
much else here this pretty much says it
all and they did get some retweets they
get some to some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on Twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your Tweet so you can use
Twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your Tweet and what you do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
I go here I could see this person is
promoting their handle but if I go down
here I can see a promoted tweet by
Constant Contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad idea
if you have some Media budget to go
ahead and either promote your Tweet or
advertise on Twitter so what that's
going to do their website and so the
whole idea when you advertise on Twitter
is really just like any other social
media platform you want to put yourself
in front of the Right audience and so
Twitter's no exception so with Twitter
you could put yourself in front of the
Right audience so what you could do is
you could promote a tweet you know do
promoted Trends or you could do promoted
accounts so you have a number of
different advertising options on Twitter
what we just looked at was you know
looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objective so that's a benefit of Twitter
the cost per click it's a cost per click
model so it tends to be fairly low you
could tail your audience so again you're
picking and choosing who you want your
promoted tweet or Trend or account to be
in front of and it's targeting is based
on either engagement or it's based on
keywords I.E hashtags so really you
could tailor who you want your Tweet or
your handle to be in front of and so
that's the really the benefit of Twitter
if you have a lot of active users on
Twitter you can really put yourself in
front of those active users if they're
your relevant audience at a low cost per
click so it's definitely worth the test
so you want to offer Twitter support to
your users okay so I can't stress this
enough okay so what you want to do is
when users have questions about your
product they're more likely to tweet you
for support hence they're likely to
follow your account so don't be afraid
to use the messaging option as well so
if we go back to Twitter okay chances
are somebody might have a question for
you here you can look at big ads it's
great connecting with PPC experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using in the messaging
app but they're offering that messaging
app in the form of customer service so
don't be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy Twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your Twitter
follow account these Bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying a Twitter
followers you want to build your Twitter
following naturally Twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of Bot accounts that were paid to file
users were shuts down shut down by
Twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices in organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve Bots
and adding thousands of followers to
your Twitter account because chances are
it's just going to lead to no engagement
so create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet which somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's Twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweak
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
Twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to Tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
Twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories I mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things I do is I'm definitely one
for industry news so if I'm in the
industry of digital marketing if Google
did a recent algorithm update I'm going
to likely a tweet about it or retweet it
I also am a blogger so on my particular
website if I blog I'm gonna make sure
that blog gets over to Twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
Twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so I'm in digital
marketing I deal with pay-per-click SEO
but am I going to just do pay-per-click
and SEO no I know that analytics I know
that you know Google tag manager I know
that a b testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so I'm
going to Branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing variety to the type of content
you share so don't just stick to one
thing you know feel free to reach out a
little bit shake things up by sharing
other forms of updates like engaging
quotes some questions these work best
when complemented by an image in an act
as a great discussion starter so good
point here even if you want to Branch
out of your industry and just throw in a
nice useful quote it's always a good way
to gain some attention and get some
engagement okay let's look at another
brand and see what they've tweeted about
so we're looking at Forester here so
think about emotional qualities and
their implications so here you can see
customers that feel surprised or
grateful or appreciated they're sharing
that Insight with you and so this was
interesting when I saw this so what I
did was I simply you see the hashtag
here for digital basically if you wanna
look at this particular study I just
went to Twitter and I typed in that
hashtag and now I'm going to be able to
see you know some of the other studies
that they've done here you can see top
10 it Trends shaping 2019 so I'm just
file following the Twitter handle that
they used so Forester does a lot of good
research a lot of good insights and so
what they've done here that makes this
tweet look so good is they've actually
put an image of the results in the Tweet
so they used an image to help gain
engagement or increase engagement notice
they also gave a shout out to somebody
as well as used some good hashtagging so
good tweet this was back in 2016 but
again a good use of the image with the
Tweet so you want to organize tweet
chats to interact with your users and
bring in new followers so you know you
basically want to be organized when
you're dealing with with chats so tweet
chats enable you send out tweets on a
particular topic using a designated
hashtag so during a certain time to
interact with your your followers and
other users so you could do it at a
specific time to really get out a
specific topic but you want to be able
to stay organized so that you know you
what you're chatting about is reaching
body audience and you're getting the
right following and the right engagement
okay you can also pin your best updates
and tweets to your profile so you can
just use that pin and what that's going
to do is pin it to the top and keep it
there so that you know people who go to
your Twitter handle are going to be able
to see that best tweet that you've done
so what you want to do here is use the
one that's most engaging so pinning your
best update or tweet meaning the one
that's really had a lot of Engagement
meaning retweets and followers and likes
you want to do that you want to pin that
to your profile and that will enable
first-time visitors to see it and if
they could see something that other
people engaged with and that's going to
encourage them to share and probably
follow you so and and that's always what
you want to do you always want to put
your best foot forward so pin your best
tweet to your profile so I mentioned
this earlier use tools to schedule when
to publish your tweets so here are some
of the most popular platforms terms you
know I eat Sprout social so if we take a
look at Sprout social here I'm in Sprout
social I'm connected to my Twitter
account I can simply just start tweeting
about something here so you can see it's
going to let me know how many characters
I have remaining so 280 to start out
with when I'm done tweeting notice I can
add an emoji I can upload media I can
tag a specific location okay I can even
you know call out a specific Twitter
profile now I could schedule this myself
or I can use the schedule below I could
pick and choose a time to schedule the
Tweet now again you want to be able to
use the Sprout social whatever social
media tool you're using to figure out
when the best time of day and the day of
the week to actually tweet when are you
getting the best engagement so ideally
that's what you want to do you want to
tweet when you're likely to get the best
engagement when those eyeballs are
actually going to look at that tweet
okay but you also want want to separate
out your tweets so they're not on one on
top of another because if you actually
Tweet back to back then those tweets are
just going to get buried so if you
spread them out a little bit then you're
likely to maximize your number of
Impressions or eyeballs on that tweet so
if you schedule a tweet multiple Tweets
in the same day then post them a few
hours apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just Sprout
social HootSuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active Okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaging
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine-tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with Wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember Randy's
gave away that free Frosty you don't be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contests can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
Twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if I just go to my website here if I
scroll down we actually have you know
Twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see I just retweeted the simply learned
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what I retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely even get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active Twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
going to show up on your website it's
going to show that hey you're fresh
you're engaging you keep up to date it's
just going to make it look good and make
your website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your Twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming to your
website that may not even know you have
a Twitter account so you can also do
this in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but I would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
Twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention and this is from PlayStation
so PlayStation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on Apple TV today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with PlayStation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happen to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
Apple TV so you never know what's going
to happen with a tweet when you tweet
good things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you as
a follower something good is going to
come out of tweeting Twitter is an easy
platform to use and if you take into
account all these best practices you are
going to increase your Twitter followers
today we're going to talk about how to
increase Instagram followers today's
webinar we're gonna have some tips and
and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase Instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about Instagram so
Instagram is not really an up and coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users fact 500 million daily
active Instagram users 500 million daily
May the user-based growth of more than
300 year over year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
Implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the Advent of mobile
technology that the Instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photos so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's a
hundred million photos plus uploaded
daily and then there are 400 million
stories posted daily so when you post
something you can create a story out of
it and there's 400 million of those per
day and then there's more than 50
billion photos shared to date so since
2010 platform Nat which is now owned by
Facebook it's become really really
popular a good place for you if you have
your own company if you have your own
brand if you have your own product it's
a good place for you to really showcase
that service that product that brand
because of the user base how easy it is
to use and the wide reach it has for you
in which to tell your story so imagine
there are lots of photos shared today
close to seven billion dollars revenue
generated through Instagram mobile so on
top of everything I just said there's a
lot of e-commerce going on here too so
Instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers a
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
Instagram which is owned by Facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
Instagram so Instagram is an e-commerce
platform to say the least in fact
Instagram is because it's so popular
because it's part of Facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on Instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're going to see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to Instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
Instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
going to go through some tips and tricks
today and we're going to talk about
everything there is to know about
Instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because Instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if I go to my Instagram account for
example using my desktop I could see my
profile and I can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear concise
and compelling bio why because this is
your introduction to the world you want
people to know who you are and because
if you don't really become very clear to
people they're not going to follow you
so this is where it all starts you need
to take advantage of your bio have a
clear and concise bio and have a link to
your website or some contact information
so to me this is where it all starts you
gotta have a bio because that's what
people are going to look at and they're
going to decide whether to follow you or
not based on primarily that bio that's
where it all starts so make sure you
have a good bio that's tip number one so
you'll have to make sure that your
landing page is also mobile optimized
since most Instagram gram users are on
mobile so if you're going to put a link
to your website and somebody's on the
Instagram app and they see your bio and
they like it and you have a link to your
website make sure that Lanny page they
go to is mobile optimized so tip number
two everything you do on Instagram when
it comes to posting evolves around
hashtags so that's the backbone of the
platform just like most platforms out
there social media platforms like
Twitter or Facebook Pinterest you're
gonna have hashtags accompany those
posts so Instagram's no different but in
this case you really really want to take
advantage of the hashtag so hashtags are
there to help users find your content so
you want to start out by using hashtags
that are relevant to your business so if
you're in the food industry you're gonna
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on Instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on Instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your Hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested fars and sales
so here really what I'm trying to say is
look pick and choose your hashtags
carefully because if you use something
broad or something non-relevant yeah you
may get that click to your Instagram
page but that doesn't necessarily mean
somebody's gonna follow you or that
doesn't really mean somebody's going to
be interested in what you have to offer
so if you use something really popular
and Broad yes you're going to get
short-term gratification but not
long-term interest tip number three post
your content at the right time so
according to sprout social which is a
social media scheduling platform among
other things so they deal with a lot of
people using their platform and posting
content via their platform they have
data and they're telling us based on the
data they've collected that the best
time to post this between 2 and 3 P.M
and the best data post is Thursday now
that may be all fine and true according
to a sprout social study and so you may
want to go with this 2 to 3 P.M and this
is probably local in case you're
wondering what time zone you're
referring to so this is all local to you
so go ahead and try that out try two to
three p.m on Thursday the thing is what
you're gonna have to do eventually is
figure out what the best time to post is
okay so if you're pointing out a lot of
content and you're putting out content
throughout the week at certain times of
the day or throughout the day you're
gonna have to determine which time of
day and what day is generating the best
engagement for you who's looking at your
post at what point of the day what day
of the week and so you're going to
really have to lean on a social media
platform to help you determine that
because they're going to have the data
that you need to determine what the best
time of day to post is okay so we'll
talk about social media platforms here
shortly we just know that when you post
post with some rationale in mind ask
yourself before you even push that
publish button or before you even
schedule that post this time of day in
this day of the week makes sense so you
always want to post at the right time
because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and Instagram also has some
analytics for business account so
Instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitors brand then what the chance
of them liking your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted okay engage with them okay it
doesn't take that much time it's a good
way to gain followers so if we're on
Instagram we can simply just click on
the Brand's followers so here I can see
this brand has 127 followers and here I
can see all the followers and what I
could do is simply just click on one of
the followers and I can go to their
profile and from there I could see what
they've posted in terms of videos and
images and I can like or comment so just
doing something as simple as this gets
you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five pay for sponsored
posts and product reviews so a number of
ways you could do this here so pay for
sponsored post so you can find an
influer who satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect connect with them and
ask them for sponsored post pricing so
it's as simple as that as reaching out
to somebody who has a large following
okay so if you do this then it's going
to put shoe in front of a large number
of people and so by doing this it'll
help expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address in their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or Shadow so that's the
key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting them
with them on being a sponsor to one of
your posts okay you want to get yourself
out there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability Okay so so tag your
images videos or stories by tagging the
location City or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your text so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip seven
use Instagram stories to track followers
and grow your user base So Stories a
really big feature on Instagram so what
stories could be used for is just show
footage of an environment so it could be
your office it could be your home it
could be you know the playground it
could be the golf course it could be
anywhere that you you want to show
vintage of so you want to post new
relevant to your industry so if you're
in the food industry hey why not go in
the back into the kitchen and post a
story about how a particular bread or
cake is made okay show off your product
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're in the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an Instagram Story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a YouTube
video or you can create an Instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog post you can
post positive user reviews so these are
all features of a story increased
interactivity with polls sliders Etc and
then you can also mention and other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of Instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
Instagram stories is a really big
feature with Instagram check it out you
know you just do a search for Instagram
stories in fact let's get some of you
users involved what best practices do
you have when creating Instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
Instagram story with us by putting that
Instagram story in the comment section
below so we want to get everybody
involved here because there's a
thousands upon thousands of great
Instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your Instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
so your stories could teach or promote
something to your user base so always
keep that in the back of your mind you
know for me I always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you you know people
who are following you are interested in
food if you're a pizza company you know
show off that pizza if you're a bakery
show off how you make your Breads and
goods baked goods whatever it is you
have show it off because if somebody's
following you that's what they're
interested in so tip number eight
highlight important stories so you want
to highlight highlights serve as the
easiest way to create a first impression
for a potential follower so with
highlights can be used to tease what
your content's about create a trailer
for what your brand offers promote and
promote your product so highlights are
there it's a good feature it's a first
impression for potential follower so it
teases what the content's about it
creates a trailer so to speak for your
brand and promote your product so use
highlights and again any users out there
who have good examples of highlights go
ahead and put those in the content
section or comment section uh right
below this video so remember stories
have only a 24-hour lifespan so
highlights can be used to give them a
second wind okay so highlights serve a
purpose it teases what the content's
about it promotes the product and it
really kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on Instagram
even if they enjoy your content so you
can ask users to become your followers
in the caption the comment section or
even work it into your content so in
other words when you're posting
something don't be afraid to say hey
follow me you know I got some good stuff
here be confident you don't want to do
it for every post of course but you know
pick and choose if you feel you have a
really good post you know really good
image that you think is going to gain a
lot of followers and engagers then you
don't necessarily need to put a caption
in there but if if it is popular then go
ahead and say hey this is a popular post
you know think about following me or put
something in the comment section you
want to do it kind of succinctly you
don't want to be begging but just
working into some degree okay but don't
Don't Be Afraid have some confidence in
asking for followers so when you do this
it's very similar to how we do it on
YouTube so you can ask viewers to
subscribe to their channels at the end
of the video so it's if on YouTube
basically you're saying hey if you like
what we have go ahead and subscribe it's
no different on Instagram if you have
something you've posted just go and said
hey you like this you know go ahead and
follow us so that's simple so tip number
10 take on the latest trends to get more
followers so align your content to cater
to trendy topics or hashtags to improve
engagement and discoverability so really
what we're trying to say here is your
competitors follow influencers what are
the latest trends and you can get an
idea of the latest trends by you looking
at hashtags so what hashtags are
trending which ones are people using the
most so really what you want to do is
whatever is trending in your industry
you know ride that wave so to speak now
it doesn't have to take on your entire
profile but there's nothing wrong with
one or two post if something's really
taking on popularity then go ahead and
post about it as well you know for
example in the wine industry if there's
a new wine that really came out that's
really gaining some popularity go ahead
and post about it with the same hashtag
and with the unique hashtag so don't be
afraid to you know ride the wave of
popularity so to speak because it shows
that you know you know what you're
talking about it adds some credibility
and it's going to get some you know
viewers over to your Instagram profile
so keep in mind you need to keep your
content relevant because if your
audience is interested in what you have
to offer then they're going to be
engaged however you know if you're
joining the discussion in a relevant
manner keep it in mind whether your
audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
YouTube just like on Facebook I mean
Instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
it's an idea of a contest well again if
you're running a pizza parlor you know
you could say hey what's your favorite
pizza or give me your favorite pizza
ideas and you can run a contest and you
know you can have people even create
their own pizza and post an image of it
you can have people create stories on
the best ways in which they create pizza
or their experience in another pizza
parlor there's lots of things you can do
to create a contest and you don't always
have to give something away you could
just do something for fun especially if
you have a lot of followers if you have
a lot of followers and somebody's going
to take part in it so don't be afraid to
run contests just to make it fun and
light it up a little bit so each tag can
bring you a new audience member who
could be a potential follower so anytime
you run a contest people are gonna tag
their friends to let them know about
that contest so those friends are gonna
come over and likely engage so that's
the beauty of running a contest or
giveaway is chances are words gonna
spread and it's gonna get you some new
followers so that's the the end benefits
so to speak but the real benefit is
keeping your audience engaged so tip
number 12 we want to stay consistent
with posts so having a consistent pace
and theme for your post can have a huge
impact to convert visitors so when we
say consistent you know if you're again
that pizza parlor stay within Pizza you
could Branch out a little maybe and talk
about salads or talk about beverages to
you know as a complimentary factor to
the pizza okay but don't talk about
hamburgers if you're focused in on pizza
so we wanted to stay consistent with
your theme this method involves less
effort with a faster production of
Instagram content so than me what we're
really trying to say here is focus stay
focused on who you are if you do that if
you're consistent and you're gaining
some followers and that's what people
are coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's going to muddy
the water supposed so to speak and
you're probably going to get less
engagement so set a theme on Instagram
by maintaining consistency and your
personality filters colors and layouts
and really what I'm referring to is post
and when you have post something you're
you're really creating a personality for
yourself okay so if you're in fashion
for example and you're in the jeans
industry well jeans jeans jeans right
that's your personality accentuate it
with different outfits related to jeans
but you know when you start talking
about dresses and shoes and and that
kind of blurs your your personality a
bit so if you stay consistent within
jeans and outfits that go with jeans
then I think people are going to start
to pick up on that personnel so tip 13
keep track of your Instagram following
so you can analyze the growth of your
Channel with tools like socialblade I
could tell you how many followers you
lost over time and how engaged they are
okay so you can use data gather from
here and from Instagram business account
to diagnose where you're faltering so
let's take a look at socialblade as an
example here so if I go over here I'm
going to go to socialblade here I can
enter in basically any account after a
register and I could see how that
account has performed you know where
they rank you know how many uploads they
have what country they focused on one
industry and the beauty here is I could
see and I'm looking at YouTube as an
example I could see you know how my post
to perform well you could do this for
Instagram you could do it for Facebook
so you can really get an idea of how
your accounts performing so socialblade
is a great platform for measuring and
again you do also have Instagram
business insights so with Instagram
business insights basically what you're
going to do is you're going to go to
your app right and then from the app you
can basically look at your insights from
there so in the app itself you're going
to click on the upper right three lines
and from there you're going to see
insights and when you go to insights
you're also going to see you know what
your reach is how many Impressions and
some engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the Instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns in post what post
receive the most amount of Engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use Instagram ads so Instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with Instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mentioned this on other webinars for
Facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if I go back into say
Facebook ads manager I can pick and
choose my placements and really what I
want to do is pick and choose for
example Instagram and so I have
Instagram feed I have Instagram stories
so and I could see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on Instagram so with
Instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
Carousel Sue really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
Facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
sizes your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
going to get all that information when
you run your ads on Facebook ads manager
but it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the Facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting you this you
need meaning you know who saw the ad did
they click on it okay you can refine
that target audience you can go back
into Facebook ads manager and refine who
your audience is so lots of flexibility
here on advertising on Instagram but the
key here is if you want to run
advertising on Instagram you know think
about what it is you're trying to
promote if you feel something needs to
get promoted then go ahead and you know
you can either again reach out to
somebody and have them sponsor it or you
can run it as an advertise so let's move
on to tip 15. so we want to create
visually attractive and eye-catching ads
so if you are going to run ads you know
here's some things to keep in mind okay
you want to use images that are natural
and seem native okay you don't want to
use any stock photography first off you
want to use something that you've done
okay you want to minimize the amount of
text so let the image do the talking you
want to ensure your caption relates to
the image and resonates with your
audience okay so you have an opportunity
to add some text below the image okay so
make sure it resonates and then of
course use hashtags to show your ads to
Target your audience but a wider
relevant audience so hashtags do play a
role here as well so these are some tips
if you're going to create ads you want
to take these into account the whole
point of the ad is to get people over to
either web page or to your profile page
okay so that they can engage and take
action so Instagram ads will help
showcase your product service or brand
in a way that's memorable and unique so
if you really want to get your vision
your brand your product out there in
front of a lot of people then
advertising on Instagram is a good way
to do that so since we've been talking
about pizza throughout this webinar this
is a good Instagram a profile here about
pizza you know I'm getting hungry just
looking at this hopefully this is an
example for all veg and non-veg pizza
consumers I mean you can see this
profile here they got the website you
know they got the handle okay so they
have a lot of followers so you know if
I'm in the pizza industry I can go ahead
and you know click on their followers
and see who who's following them who
they're following so some really good
shots of pizza here it looks like you
know a lot of people are wearing were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage Instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so here you know you could
say use daily Pizza as a hashtag for
feature okay so they're even encouraging
you to use a specific hashtag so you can
really do a lot here on Instagram this
is just a good example of what you can
do and have fun with you know with an
example like pizza just to give you some
ideas so let's move on to tip 16 take
advantage of Instagram tools so you